FOR BEING HERE WE'RE JUST
WAITING FOR EITHER TO MORE
DEMOCRATS ARE ONE REPUBLICAN SO
WE CAN GET STARTED WITH THE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
OR WITH A QUORUM FORGET TO MORE
DEMOCRATS
.
FREDDIE -- ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS STAFFS THAT ARE OUT
THERE WATCHING ON TV PLEASE GO
FIND YOUR MEMBER.
AND HAVE THEM REPORT TO WERE
RUMORS IS. FOR FOR FOR AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU
.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY THIS IS
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE OF MAY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SINCE THE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR WAS
RELEASED ONE ITEM HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT ITEM IS MINE.
AB SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN WHICH ARE
PRESENT LATER IN THIS HEARING.
THAT LEAVES US WITH SIX ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER
THREE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AND
NUMBER SIX AND NUMBER SEVEN AND
NUMBER NINE AND NUMBER -- TEN WE
WERE NOT GOING TO GET TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR YET -- BEFORE
WE DO THAT LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAYES MULLIN.
WEBER HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW
WE HAVE A QUORUM DOES ANY MEMBER
WAS TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND ON TEN I'M NUMBER TEN A. B.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINE BY THE
ELECTIONS IN ADDITION COMMITTEE.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THOSE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESSED THE
OPPOSITION THAT IS OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS WITH THAT DOES ANY
NUMBER WHICH TO PULL ANYTHING
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE.
BERMAN.
HI BERMAN I GALLAGHER GALLAGHER
AYE CALDERON LOW.
MAYES MULLIN MULLIN AYE WEBER
WEBER I THE BILL IS OUT ON THE
FOR A VOTE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT UP
WE HAVE MISTER OBERNOLTE WITHOUT
A NUMBER. TWO AB.
SIX TEN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
TO MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AB SIX
TENS A VERY SIMPLE BILL
CURRENTLY STATE LAW REQUIRES
THAT WHEN A BALLOT IS PLACED ON
I'M SORRY WHEN A BOND MEASURES
PLACED ON THE BALLOT FOR VOTER
APPROVAL.
THAT ESTIMATE FOR THE TAX RATE
REQUIRED TO SERVICE THE BOND
ALSO BE PLACED IN THE LANGUAGE
FOR THE BALLOT STATEMENT.
CURRENTLY STATE LAW REQUIRES
THAT.
X. RAY TO BE EXPRESSED IN
DOLLARS PER.
HUNDRED SO DOLLARS PER HUNDRED
DOLLARS OF ASSESSED VALUE
HOWEVER.
ACCORDING TO ZILLOW THE AVERAGE
VALUE OF A HOUSE IN CALIFORNIA
IS OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHICH REQUIRES A FAIR
BIT OF MATH ON THE PART OF THE
VOTER TO FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT
THEIR TAX RATE WOULD BE ON THEIR
PROPERTY.
SO THIS BILL AB SIX TEN SIMPLY
REQUIRES THAT TAX RATE TO BE
EXPRESSED IN DOLLARS PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
HAD A THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR HOUSE.
YOU WOULD JUST HAVE TO MULTIPLY
BY THREE INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT
WHICH WOULD BE ME OF THIRTY
THOUSAND SO ARE THERE IS A JUST
ONE LOT OF OPPOSITION THAT WE'VE
GOT NOT THAT THAT'S FROM THE
COALITION FOR AFFORDABLE -- I'M
SORRY THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
SCHOOL HOUSING IN THAT
OPPOSITION LETTER THEY EXPRESSED
THE OPINION THAT -- IT WOULD BE
BETTER FOR VOTERS TO HAVE TO USE
A CALCULATOR TO FIGURE OUT THAT
TAX RATE.
I COULD NOT DISAGREE MORE WITH
THAT SENTIMENT I THINK IT'S OF
THE PROBLEM IS THAT MOST VOTERS
WILL NOT PULL OUT THE CALCULATOR
THEY'VE GOT OTHER THINGS TO DO
WITH THEIR TIME THEY'VE GOT OF
THINGS THAT THEY'RE VOTING ON I
THINK IT'S MUCH BETTER. TO HAVE
THEM BE ABLE TO LOOK AT AT THE
TAX RATE THAT'S EXPRESSED AND
HAVING THEM AND HAVE THEM
INSTANTLY BE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH A REASONABLE ESTIMATE OF
THE VALUE.
ALSO KIND OF WRITTEN BEHIND
BETWEEN THE LINES OF THE
COALITION'S LETTER A IS
SOMETHING THEY DON'T COME OUT
AND SAY IF IT'S SOMETHING THAT
I'VE HEARD FROM OTHER PEOPLE.
BY THE BELIEF THAT EXPRESSING
THE RATE PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS WOULD MAKE VOTERS LESS
LIKELY TO APPROVE BONDS YEAH AND
I ALSO VERY STRONGLY DISAGREE
WITH THAT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
RESEARCH DOES NOT SUPPORTED AT
ALL IF YOU LOOK AT THE RESEARCH.
THE MORE THAT VOTERS DON'T
UNDERSTAND OR CONFUSED ABOUT A
BALLOT MEASURE THE MORE LIKELY
THEY ARE TO SIMPLY VOTE NOW AND
SO I THINK THAT THE BETTER JOB
THAT WE CAN DO IT INFORMING THEM
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON THE
PROS AND THE CONS WHAT THEY GET
AND WHAT.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY THE
MORE LIKELY THEY ACTUALLY WILL
BE TO APPROVE.
A MEASURE ON THE BALLOT SO THIS
IS A VERY SIMPLE -- CIVIL
MEASURE THAT SO GOOD FOR VOTER
TRANSPARENCY I'D REQUEST
TRUCKLOAD.
THANK YOU MISTER MULTI -- ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
UNDER THE BILL.
I HAVE A MOTION.
I HAVE A SECOND.
THE MORNING REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION PRODUCT
AT SCHOOL HOUSING -- WE DO
OPPOSE A. B. SIX TEN WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE TRANSPARENCY AND
THE INTENTION OF COMMUNICATING
VERY CLEARLY WITH VOTERS
REGARDING THE IMPACT
IMMEASURABLE HAVE ON THEM -- THE
TAX RATE STATEMENT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS A GREAT TOOL TO
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION.
UP WE BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY SIX
TEN ACTUALLY PROVIDE PROVIDE
VOTERS WITH LASSEN SPECIFICITY
REGARDING THEIR PARTICULAR
SITUATION AND THE SPECIFIC
ASSESSED VALUATION OF THE
PROPERTY.
THAT THEY WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
VOTERS ARE MORE LIKELY UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL TO MAKE A
GUESSTIMATE BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR RANGES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THEIR HOME IS
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THEY'RE GOING
TO LOOK AND SEE THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY ACTS FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS WOULD BE A
DIFFERENT NUMBER I'M SOMEWHERE
IN THE MIDDLE -- WITH THE
CURRENT LAW AND THE TAX RATE
STATEMENT.
OF CENTS PER ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS
ASSESSED VALUATION IT'S A VERY
SIMPLE MATH CALCULATION AND YOU
CAN GET PRECISELY THE IMPACT ON
THE INDIVIDUAL VOTER AND THEIR
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCE.
SO BECAUSE OF THAT WE DO OPPOSE
EIGHTY SIX TEN IT'S AN EXAMPLE
OF UP WE BELIEVE THE CHANGES
UNNECESSARY WHAT PROBLEM ARE WE
TRYING TO SOLVE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS COULD
ACTUALLY INCREASE VOTER
CONFUSION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MR MON.
FAMOUS SHARON THANK YOU MISS
ROBIN ULTI AND I KNOW YOUR GOALS
GOOD ONE HERE TO BRING CLARITY.
FOR VOTERS I'M TRYING.
TO GET BY MY HEAD AROUND THIS
YEAR SO IT WOULD THERE BE
EXAMPLE WHERE.
IT'S PROBABLY PRETTY UNLIKELY
WITH EXAMPLES OF PROPERTY.
EVALUATION UNDER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SURE SO.
IS ON THE BALLOT MEASURE.
AND WHAT IT APPLIES TO THERE ARE
VERY MANY HOMES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE WORTH UNDER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS CERTAINLY
VACANT PROPERTIES -- A LOT OF
THEM ARE WORTH HUNDRED UNDER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND MANY BONDS
DON'T APPLY TO THE VACANT
PROPERTIES BUT SOME DO -- WHAT
ELSE POSSESSORY INTERESTS THAT'S
ANOTHER THING THAT SOMETIMES
THAT CERTAINLY ON PROPERTY TAX
RULES SOMETIMES BONDS CAPTURE
THOSE SOMETIMES THEY DON'T BOB
ON SECURE PROPERTY LIKE BOATS?
BOB CERTAINLY MANY OF THOSE
WORTH UNDER THE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS AGAIN SOME BONDS CAPTURE
THOSE SOME DON'T -- BUT THE
OTHER VAST MAJORITY WOULD BE
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND THANK
YOU FOR THAT'S HOUSE YOU KNOW
THINKING ALONG THE LINES OF OF
HOMES BUT YEAH THERE'S A WHOLE
RANGE OF PROPERTIES THAT WOULD
BE INCLUDED HERE CELL.
I THINK A HUNDRED DOLLARS THIS
IS PRETTY PRETTY LOW AND THAT
DOES REQUIRE A CALCULATOR TO
COME OUT.
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED SOMETHING
LIKE A THOUSAND DOLLARS WHERE --
YOU KNOW PEOPLE THINK IN TERMS
OF PROPERTY VALUE IN.
THE END THOUSANDS INCREMENTS OF
A THOUSAND YOU KNOW MY CONDO NOW
MY CONDO A CONDO -- WORTH TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU
KNOW YOU DO THAT MATH TWO
HUNDRED TIMES THAT NUMBER YOU
SEE.
ON THE BALLOT IS THAT A SIMPLER
CALCULATION OF CLARITY IS THE
GOAL.
I GUESS MY CONCERN IS IF YOU
MAKE IT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR STANDARD AND YOU'VE GOT
PROPERTY LESS THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND THAT CAN BE MISLEADING
I WOULD THINK UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO IF CLARITY IS THE ULTIMATE
GOAL HERE'S OUR A SIMPLER WAY TO
DO THIS THAT.
IS MORE INCLUSIVE OF ALL
PROPERTY -- BUT BUT BRINGS
ADDITIONAL CLARITY IN.
AND OUT.
NOT IN MY CASE I'M NOT VERY GOOD
AT MATH BUT FOR SOME FOLKS THEY
MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO THAT
THOUSAND DOLLAR INCREMENTS
CALCULATION AND THEY'RE HEADING
IN A VERY -- QUICK SNAPSHOT OF
WHAT THEY'D BE PAY YOU KNOW IT
IT'S AN INTERESTING QUESTION
BECAUSE I THINK THAT PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND IS SIMPLER IF YOU HAVE
A HOME IT'S WORTH MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND ODD.
HOWEVER PER THOUSAND WOULD BE A
VAST IMPROVEMENT OVER WHAT WE
HAVE BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO EVEN
FIGURE OUT WITH THE MATH THAT
YOU'D LIKE TO DO.
USING EXAMPLE FROM THE
OPPOSITION'S WATER BECAUSE I'M
FAIR MINDED THAT WAY.
THE THE OPPOSITION'S LETTER THE
EXAMPLES A HOUSE WORTH THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
AND EXPRESS TACK RATE IS A
NICKEL PER HUNDRED DOLLARS SO
JUST THINK FOR A MINUTE.
WHAT YOU WOULD DO EVEN IF YOU
HAVE A CALCULATOR SITTING IN
FRONT OF YOU TO DO THAT
CONVERSION?
BUT MOST CALIFORNIANS I CANNOT
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO BUT IT'D
BE MUCH SUPPORT WITH PER
THOUSAND JUST MULTIPLIED BY THE
NUMBER OF THOUSANDS.
IN YOUR VALUES SO THAT WOULD BE
MULTIPLIED BY THREE SEVENTY FIVE
WOULD BE A LOT EASIER TO FIGURE
OUT SO -- THAT BUT I THINK A
HUNDRED PER HUNDRED THOUSAND IS
BETTER PER THOUSAND IS A VAST
IMPROVEMENT OVER.
OVER WHAT WE'VE GOT NOW AND AND
FRANKLY JUST I'M WORKING MY WAY
THROUGH THE STAGES OF GRIEF HERE
I'VE GOTTEN A BARGAINING SO.
HI IF IF THE COMMITTEE WOULD BE
OKAY WITH EXPRESSING THE REAPER
THOUSAND I'D BE WILLING TO AMEND
THE BILL THAT WAY.
SO I FEAR THAT I'VE MADE OF
SURPRISE THE CHAIR HERE WITH
THAT SUGGESTION AND SOMETHING
THAT I JUST THE THOUGHT OF QUITE
LITERALLY ON THE ELEVATOR UP
HERE.
BUT THE BILL BEFORE US IS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND I'D HAVE TROUBLE SUPPORTING
THE BILL BEFORE US.
BUT MORE THAN HAPPY -- TO TO
TALK WITH -- THE CHAIR IN AND
YOU ON A SIDE BAR SEE THERE SOME
OTHER WAY TO GET OUT WHAT YOU'RE
HOPING TO GET OUT HERE MISTER
OBERNOLTE
.
BOBBY ON A LITTLE EARLIER THAN I
PLANNED ON BEING ON MY IS MY
CONCERN I APPRECIATE THAT -- AND
WAS A THOUGHT THAT I'D HAD IT
WHEN -- YEAH I READ MISTER WANT
OR MISTER OBERNOLTE IS BILL IT'S
FUNNY WHEN I WAS DOING THE
CALCULATIONS I ACTUALLY FIND
FOUND MYSELF AND AND THINKING
THE OTHER TWO GOALS AND AND I
APPRECIATE.
THE THE AUTHORS GOALS -- OF OF
CLARITY BUT I THINK WE ALSO NEED
ACCURACY -- AND WE CAN'T
SACRIFICE ACCURACY.
IN IT FOR THE SAKE OF SIMPLICITY --
AND I THINK WE OWE IT TO VOTERS
TO PROVIDE ACCURATE INFORMATON
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO GET TO AN
ACCURATECALCULATION OF WHAT
THEY DO.
IN A BOND MEASURE WHICH IS WHY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS DOES
NOT DO THAT -- AND I DO NOT
SUPPORT THAT WHEN I WAS DOING MY
CALCULATION ACTUALLY. FOR NOT I
DON'T EXPECT THIS BUT HOW MUCH
OF GOING THE OTHER WAY.
WHICH IS EVERYONE MAKE IT EASY
FOR VOTERS THEN DO IT PER DOLLAR.
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH YOUR HOUSE IS
WORTH YOU KNOW HOW MUCH YOUR
CONDO IS WORKING ON THAT YOUR
PROPERTY IS WORTH.
AND YOU TO IF YOU HAVE THAT THE
PER DOLLAR CALCULATION ON THE
BALLOT THEN YOU JUST MULTIPLY IT
BY HOW MUCH YOUR PROPERTY IS
WORTH AND YOU GET TO A SIMPLE
CALCULATIONS ARE ACTUALLY CUTS
OUT THE STEPS.
THERE'S NO.
YOU TAKE THE TOTAL TOTAL VALUE
OF YOUR PROPERTY YOU DIVIDE IT
BY SOME INCREMENT IN THE U.
MULTIPLIED BY NUMBER.
YOU JUST MULTIPLY IT BY A NUMBER --
AND SO I GUESS I'M ON OPEN TO
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT A
THOUSAND DOLLARS I STILL THINK
IT'S IT'S DIE I DON'T KNOW THAT
IT REALLY MAKES THINGS THAT MUCH.
EASIER FOR VOTERS -- I THINK
GOING TO A DOLLAR FRANKLY MAKES
IT IF THE GOAL IS EASE AN
ACCURACY.
THAN GOING TO A DOLLAR PROVIDES
EASE AND ACCURACY IT CUTS OUT
THE STEPS THAT YOU HAVE TO TAKE
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO DETERMINE
HOW MUCH YOU OWE IN A BOND
MEASURE AND I THINK THAT SHOULD
BE OUR GOAL -- AS GOVERNMENT SO --
THAT YOU KNOW I I I APPRECIATE --
YOU KNOW THE THE THE EFFORTS AT
AT YOU KNOW FINDING -- A
COMPROMISE I JUST I I JUST DON'T
KNOW THAT THAT REALLY HELPS --
AND AND SO I YOU KNOW TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION I DON'T KNOW IF I
WOULD SUPPORT THAT -- I THINK I
THINK THE AUTHORS GOT TIME --
YOU KNOW I I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT'S NECESSARY TO HAVE THIS --
GOING TO AFFECT IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND SO I THINK OF THE AUTHOR
WANTED. TO TO YOU KNOW.
TURN THIS INTO A TWO YEAR BILL
AND AND GIVE MORE TIME FOR
CONVERSATIONS THAT SOMETHING
THAT CAN HAPPEN -- BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF ON THE SPOT RIGHT NOW ON
THE IN A PLACE TO SUPPORT A
THOUSAND DOLLARS VERSUS A
HUNDRED DOLLARS I DON'T KNOW.
THAT IT MAKES THINGS SO MUCH
EASIER AND I THINK IT MIGHT MAKE
THINGS.
I DON'T THINK IT MAKES IT ANY
BETTER THAN THE CURRENT
SITUATION [inaudible]
PLEASE -- I'VE I MEAN I JUST
THINK IT DOES MAKE IT A LOT
SIMPLER AND THE MOST THINGS ARE
IN THE HUNDRED THOUSANDS MOST OF
THE YOU KNOW.
PROPERTY TAXES THAT WE'RE GONNA
DEAL WITH DEAL WITH YOUR HOME
AND OUR HOMES ARE ARE WORTH A
WHOLE LOT MORE THAN. HUNDRED
DOLLAR INCREMENTS NOW -- SO IT
IS TO ME IT IS IT DOES MAKE IT
SIMPLER AND A FOR IF THE IDEA TO
MAKE IT SIMPLER.
SO THE VOTERS CAN BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH THIS IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO COST THEM.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S A REGIONAL
MEASURE WE CAN WORK THROUGH WHAT
THAT SHOULD BE.
I MEAN THIS STILL GOT TO GO
THROUGH A LOT OF PROCESS AFTER
pWOULD ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE ON
IT -- OBVIOUSLY AUTHOR CAN
DECIDE WHAT HE WANTS TO DO TERMS
OF MAKING IT TO BILL TO YOUR
BILL OR NOT BUT I JUST FEEL LIKE
WE HAVE A LOT OF PROCESS TO GO
HERE AND WE CAN PROBABLY FIGURE
OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S HE REMINDS ME OF
THE BIBLICAL.
YOU KNOW.
WHAT WAS IT SALAS KILLED AS
THOUSANDS AND DAVID IS KILLED AS
TENS OF THOUSANDS YOU KNOW?
WHICH ONE WE GET INTO YOU KNOW
IT WAS GOING 200-010-0001.
HUNDRED THOUSAND WELL YEAH. ONE
OF THOSE YOU KNOW -- BUT
WHATEVER THAT NUMBER RICHER'S
GET IT DOESN'T GO TO SYNAGOGUE
IN A WHATEVER THAT NUMBER IS --
IT YEAH I THINK IT WOULD HELP
SIMPLIFY THEM FOR YOUR SON THAT
NOT DAMAGES EXAMINER.
ON I WAS GOING TERM A MICROPHONE
OFF.
WITH WHATEVER THAT IS QUESTION A
TAKEN US DOWN THE ROAD SORRY --
WHATEVER THE NUMBERS I THINK WE
CAN MAKE IT YOU KNOW SIMPLER FOR
VOTERS AND LET'S FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DO THAT THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
MISS GHANA I APOLOGIZE FOR FOR
BEING A LITTLE LATE TRAVELING
WITH THE KIDS IN THE MORNING IS
ABSOLUTELY NO JOKE -- BUT JUST
IF YOU COULD AT IN YOU MAY HAVE
ALREADY ADDRESSES BUT YOU GET
DRESSED A KIND OF WHAT I SHARED
WITH YOU IN MY TAXED -- THIS
MORNING I IN OF THE LEGISLATURE
WHICH WE DO WE NEED TO PUT
SOMETHING ON THE BALLOT
SOMETIMES IT'S OUT OF NECESSITY
BECAUSE WERE IN A SIGNIFICANT.
ECONOMIC RECESSION I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY WE MITIGATE THOSE
ISSUES BY HAVING A RAINY DAY
FUND UP IN THE EVENT THAT WE
NEED TO PUT A BOND ON THE BALLOT
FOR A REALLY SIGNIFICANT REASON.
AND VOTERS ARE LOOKING AT THE
NUMBERS DIFFERENTLY IN THERE
LOOKING AT A BIGGER NUMBER THIS
TIME THEY COULD DISCOURAGE
VOTERS FROM BEING ABLE -- TO GET
THEMSELVES TO POSITION WHERE
THEY CAN SUPPORT THAT MEASURE --
AND YOU KNOW IT'S NOT THAT IT IS
AN ALREADY DIFFICULT ENOUGH TO
GET DIFFERENT BOND MEASURES THAT
WE PLACE ON THE BALLOT WHETHER
TO TAX INCREASE FOR SPECIFIC
REASON BECAUSE WE NEED FUND
EDUCATION OR WHATEVER ELSE --
BUT I I I I WOULD WANT TO HEAR
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE IMPACT THAT
IT COULD HAVE ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO STUFF THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PUTS ON THE BALLOT.
FOR A VERY VERY LEGITIMATE
REASON AND THEN ALSO IF YOU
COULD JUST BRIEFLY TOUCH BECAUSE
I KNOW YOU'VE ALREADY DONE IT --
ON THE YOUR AND YOUR NEED ARE
YOU YOU'RE PERCEIVED -- NEED FOR
THIS BILL SURE.
SO IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I VERY MUCH DISAGREE WITH THE
ASSERTION THAT THIS WOULD MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT TO GET BOUGHT
MEASURES APPROVED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RESEARCH.
IT VERY MUCH DOES NOT SUPPORT
THAT CONCLUSION BECAUSE THERE
BEEN MANY MANY STUDIES DONE ON
VOTER BEHAVIOR -- YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THEY ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WITH A VESTED INTEREST IN
INFLUENCING VOTER BEHAVIOR.
AND THE STUDIES SHOW OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AT THAT THE
MORE CONFUSION THAT VOTERS HAVE
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE VOTING ON THE
MORE LIKELY THEY ARE TO VOTE NO.
AND SO I ACTUALLY THINK THAT IF
IT'S CLEAR TO A VOTER.
NOT ONLY THE COST BUT ALSO THE
BENEFIT.
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE MORE
LIKELY TO GET TO A YES AND SO
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO PROMOTE
THAT TRANSPARENCY I ACTUALLY
THINK THAT I MEAN IF YOU LOOK AT
YES GAS POLITICAL CONSULTANTS
WILL TELL YOU.
IF YOU WANNA KILL AN INITIATIVE
JUST MAKE SURE IT'S AS CONFUSING
AS POSSIBLE AND YOU GO OUT THERE
YOU SOW CONFUSION AND THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WOULD YOU DO TO GET
VOTERS TO VOTE NO. TO TRY TO
MAKE IT SOUND LIKE IT'S SO
COMPLICATED THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE MOST LIKELY I CHECKED
THAT NO BOX.
AND SO I KIND OF FEEL LIKE IN
SOME CASES THAT'S WHERE WE ARE
WITH.
WITH IN OVER EXPRESSING THESE
RATES PER HUNDRED DOLLARS I MEAN
WE THE EXAMPLE WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT A MINUTE AGO IF
YOU GOT A THREE AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR HOUSE.
AND THE AND THE TAXES EXPRESSED
AS A NICKEL PER HUNDRED DOLLARS
YOU KNOW WHAT.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO WHAT DO
INTERNAL CALCULATOR DO THAT
CONVERSION I MEAN MOST OF US
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT A BUNCH?
AND IN ON ANOTHER THING I THINK
IT'S WORTH SAYING ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE IT'S GERMANE TO OUR
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER THEY
SHOULD BE FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER THOUSAND DOLLARS OR FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
HE IS -- COMES FROM THE STUDY OF
OF HUMAN MACHINE INTERFACE.
WHICH IS AT A FIELD THAT THE
DECISION OFF MY COMPANY IS -- IN
A DOES WORK IN.
WHAT WE CALL THAT PROCESS ON
BOARDING PROCESS BETWEEN WHEN A
USER STARTS IN AND WHEN A USER
COMPLETES DOING WHAT'S SOMETHING
WE WANT THEM TO DO?
AND THERE'S A LOT OF RESEARCH
THAT SAYS THAT EVERY SINGLE STEP
THAT YOU FORCE THE USER TO TAKE
BETWEEN THE BEGINNING A ON THE
OUT COOPER THE DESIRED OUTCOME
MAKES THEM LESS LIKELY TO FINISH
SO IF YOU.
TALK ABOUT IT THAT IN THIS CASE
IF WE'RE SAYING WE WANT TO PER
FOR PEOPLE TO USE A CALCULATOR
THAT MEANS THAT EVERY.
NUMBER THAT THEY HAVE TO PUSH ON
THE CALCULATOR MAKES IT LESS
LIKELY THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
FINISH AND MORE LIKELY THAT
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO SAY TO
HECK WITH IT I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
HOW TO CALCULATE THIS RAID AND
SO THAT'S WHY THAT THAT WOULD BE
MARKETED AS TO WHY -- THOUSAND
IS BETTER THAN A HUNDRED AND A
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS BETTER THAN
THOUSAND BECAUSE I WOULD A
MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF WORK THE
VOTER HAS TO DO TO GET IT TO GET
TO AN ACCURATE ANSWER.
AND THIS IS AND THERE WASN'T A
SPECIFIC INCIDENT NO IT WAS JUST
YOUR THIS IS IN GENERAL TERMS
YOU EAT YOUR PURE AUTHOR HIS
BILL BECAUSE YOU PERCEIVE IT TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THE VOTER TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION OF WHETHER
OR NOT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THEY WANT. TO TAKE ON AND ON YES
AND AS I'M SURE MOST THE PEOPLE
ON THE COMMITTEE NO I I'VE A
LONG -- INTEREST IN THIS.
IN THIS FIELD I'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF BILLS.
THAT THE IN THIS AREA IN FACT
THE REQUIREMENT TO PUTTHAT.
OUR TAX RATE ON THE STATEMENT
CAME FROM THE BILL THAT I
AUTHORED A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT -- I
HAVE A DEEP INTEREST IN ART
CONTINUED TO TO LOOK AT AS THE
REFORMS WE PUT IN PLACE HAVE OR
HAVE ROLLED OUT TO SEE WHAT
TWEAKS NEED TO BE MADE. TO MAKE
IT MORE EFFECTIVE IN THIS IS ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED -- I FOUND MYSELF
GOING BACK AND FORTH BEFORE
BEFORE YOU YOU ASKED FOR A
MEETING AND I HAD SAT DOWN AND
DID A LOT OF CALCULATIONS I WAS
GOING TO BE SATISFIED WITH A
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THEN WHEN I ACTUALLY SAT
DOWN AND DID IT THAT WAS WHEN I
CAME TO THE CAN I CAN'T READ MY
CONCLUSION WHICH I THINK IS THAT
THE DOLLARS EASIER FOR TRYING TO
MAKE IT.
EASY FOR VOTERS AND GET ACCURACY --
BUT IF.
YOU WANTED TO TO OFFER UP TO
CHANGE IT TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS --
I WOULD NOT -- THAT WOULD
SUPPORT THAT.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S A VAST IMPROVEMENT
OVER THE CURRENT STATE OF
AFFAIRS OF IN USING OUR EXAMPLE
THREATEN TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR HOUSE.
IF YOU EXPRESS A PER THOUSAND
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS MULTIPLY
BY THREE SEVENTY FIVE I THINK
IT'S VERY CLEAR SO -- I WILL --
I WILL COMMIT TO TAKING THAT
AMENDMENT TO MAKE IT PER
THOUSAND DOLLARS CAD PER.
HUNDRED THOUSAND SO WITH THAT
AMENDMENT -- I'LL CHANGE MY
RECOMMENDATION FROM A NOTE.
I KEEP IT IS A NON -- BUT I'LL
BE SUPPORTING IT THANK YOU.
FOR A SECOND.
THERE'S PROBABLY SOME PROCEDURE
THAT WE NEED TO TO GET THIS
RIGHT [inaudible] TO JOINT
[inaudible]
JOHN IN CASE THE ORIGINAL MOTION
IS WITHDRAWN -- THERE IS YOU
WANNA MAKE A NEW MOTION.
SECOND.
WITH THE AMENDMENT THAT IS A FAT
PER THOUSAND INSTEAD OF PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND SO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND -- ANY
ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS PLEASE
DODD WEBER.
FIND THIS RATHER HUMOROUS.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE MOVING TO THAT TO THE
OTHER SIDE BECAUSE I I GUESS IT
IS IT IS A BETTER CALCULATION.
I JUST FIND IT HUMOROUS BECAUSE
IT'S TO TALK ABOUT THE SAD STATE
OF MATHEMATICS IN OUR YES IT
DOES WE HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY.
WE WENT BUT I THOUGHT MY GOD
HERE WE GOT TO THIS POINT YOU
KNOW WHERE -- YOU KNOW IT I FEEL
LIKE I MADE ONE OF THE FAST FOOD
RESTAURANTS WITH THE YOUNG LADY
HAS TO TRULY PUSH IN EVERYTHING
THAT SHE CAN'T GIVE ME CHANGE
AND I'VE HAD.
TO HOLD HER HAND IF TELLER WHAT
THE GIVEN A SELL OUT ANYWAY IT'S
INTERESTING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BREAKING THE BILL FOR JUST.
DOCTOR WEBER THAT'S A
CONVERSATION THE MISTER WILL
THERE ARE OBERNOLTE AND I HAD
YESTERDAY.
YEAH -- AND YOU SEE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING WITH ME
I THINK THIS TO BE GOOD FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND I'D REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I DID
THERE'S NO MORE FOR ME TO SAY --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
VOTE.
BERMAN HI BERMAN I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE CALDERON CALDERON
I LOW.
WELL I MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN MULLIN AYE
WEBER.
WEBER HI THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU.
NEXT OF A SINISTER BONTA.
WITHOUT A NUMBER ONE AB.
TWO TWENTY MORE MATURE AND
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. TO PRESENT
A. B. TWO TWENTY WHICH WILL HELP
PARENTS WITH YOUNG CHILDREN RUN
FOR PUBLIC OFFICE.
AND INCREASED GENDER PARITY
AMONG PUBLIC ELECTED OFFICIALS.
BY AUTHORIZING THE USE OF
CAMPAIGN FUNDS THE MONEY RAISED
BY CANDIDATES FOR OFFICE TO BE
USED FOR CHILDCARE EXPENSES THAT
ARE INCURRED DUE TO CAMPAIGNING
AND WHILE SERVING IN OFFICE
CANDIDATE WITH YOUNG CHILDREN
OFTEN FACE THE PRACTICAL REALITY.
OF PAIN FOR INCREASED CHILD CARE
IN ORDER TO CAMPAIGN IN NETWORK
WHEN RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
JUST LOOK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS IS A LOT OF THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
HELLO ONE SECOND THANK YOU THIS
ALLOWED THE FEDERAL LEVEL ONE
MAKE SURE IT'S ALSO ALLOWED AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND THAT IT'S
CLEAR.
AND I WANT TO THANK AB THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
FOR THEIR SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY THAT
CAMPAIGN FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR
CHILD CARE EXPENSES THAT.
DIRECTLY RESULTS FROM CAMPAIGN
ACTIVITIES OR OFFICIAL DUTIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM AYE VOTE
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS AMBER
MALTBY A CAMPAIGN FINANCE
ATTORNEY AND ADVOCATE FOR GENDER
PARITY AMONG ELECTED OFFICIALS
GREAT.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M SO I AM HERE TODAY
I'M A PARTNER WITH THE LAW FIRM
LAST MAN BUT I'M NOT HERE
REPRESENTING.
ANY PARTICULAR CLIENT BUT RATHER
TO SPEAK FROM MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE I HAVE BEEN --
ADVISING -- CALIFORNIA STATE AND
LOCAL CANDIDATES ON CAMPAIGN
FINANCE FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS.
I'M FOR THE BETTER PART OF THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS I'VE WORKED
WITH -- ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROMOTE -- THE RECRUITMENT AND
ELECTION OF WOMEN TO OFFICE OF
PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF COLOR.
AND OVER THE COURSE OF THAT
EXPERIENCE I FIND THAT THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL IS A TWO FOLD.
NUMBER ONE I'M JUST SIMPLE
CLARITY AND THE LAW THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
HAS BEEN ADVISING THINGS LIKE
THE NINETEEN NINETY IS THAT
CANDIDATES CAN USE CAMPAIGN
FUNDS.
FOR CHILDCARE WHEN THEY'RE
CAMPAIGNING HOWEVER -- ADVICE
LETTERS ARE NOT PRESIDENTIAL
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT -- A
CANDIDATE IN TWENTY NINETEEN WHO
RELIES ON A TO AN ADVICE LETTER
FROM.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR COULD BE
PROSECUTED BY THE TWENTY
NINETEEN F. PPC BECAUSE IT'S A
NEW CONVENTION A NEW GENERAL
COUNSEL -- A NEW INTERPRETATION
SO BY CODIFYING THE ADVISORS AND
EXCITING A CLEAR STANDARD THAT
GIVES NOT ONLY CANDIDATES AND
FRANKLY THOSE OF US WHO ADVISE
CANDIDATES.
CLARITY ON WHAT THEY MAY OR MAY
NOT DEAL WITH CAMPAIGN FINANCE --
IT ALSO GIVES OF THE F. PPC --
NEEDED GUIDANCE AS WELL.
THE SECOND REASON THIS BILL IS
NEEDED IS -- AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA MENTION CANDIDATES FACE
THE VERY PRACTICAL REALITY THAT.
THERE IS A PERSONAL EXPENSE
RELATED TO RUNNING FOR OFFICE
AND FOR WOMEN -- THE DECISION TO
RUN FOR OFFICE OR CARE FOR
CHILDREN IS OFTEN ONE THAT THEY
HAVE TO MAKE EARLY ON AND WHAT.
I FIND -- I'VE I WAS CHAIRED THE
EMERGE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR TWO AND A HALF
YEARS I'VE BEEN TRAINING.
THE PROGRAM CLASS -- FOR ALMOST
EIGHT YEARS NOW EVERY SINGLE
YEAR -- WE SEE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WOMEN -- DECLINED TO RUN
UNTIL THEIR CHILDREN ARE GROWN
AND OUT OF THE HOUSE SO THIS
BILL NOT ONLY -- PERMITS MORE
GENDER EQUITY IN OFFICE BUT ALSO
SUPPORTS ADAM.
A YOUNG PARENTS WITH CHILDREN
RUNNING FOR OFFICE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I I URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT AB TWO TWENTY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IT HAD A CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DEAL GIVES WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION -- IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE FOR THE REASONS
STATED -- WELL YES THIS IS ALSO
A A GREAT BILL FOR WOMEN THIS
THIS AFFECTS ALL GENDERS AS A
YOUNG PARENT MYSELF -- THE
NUMBER OF TIMES I THOUGHT YOU
KNOW WHAT.
I'D LIKE TO RUN FOR OFFICE SAID
AT AT BUT THE THOUGHT OF YOU
KNOW WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE.
TO PAY.
BUT I JUST I I APPRECIATE THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S A COMMONSENSE
MEASURE THAT THAT WILL CREATE
GREATER DIVERSITY -- IN OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS OF THAT -- WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DISREGARD THE POLITICAL ADVICE
HE GOT FROM A THE MEMBER ASIA ON
THE LONG ON BEHALF SECRETARY
STATE ALEX BUT THE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR FELL UPON OF HAVE
THE FOR PUBLIC PRACTICE MISSION
A TWEENER SURE INFAMOUS TWEENER
CATEGORY -- WE'RE SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED -- WERE VERY CLOSE TO
GETTING TO OUR SUPPORT POSITION
WE WENT TAKE -- AS MALTBY IN
MISTER BONTA AND HIS STAFF FOR
THE GREAT AND PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WE WE'VE HAD IN
REGARDS -- TO DEALING WITH
ISSUES HIGHLIGHTED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS -- WE I THINK THE
COMMISSION I STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE POLICY WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DEAL WITH THOSE FINER
DETAILS -- TO DEAL WITH REASON
BEFORE SIEBEL WE BELIEVE ABUSES
THAT COULD OCCUR -- BECAUSE THIS --
DAYCARE AND AND CHILD CARE IS
INHERENTLY PERSONAL OB THAT IT
BENEFITS CANDIDATES PERSONALLY
AND SO THERE'S THERE'S MANY LAWS
ON THE BOOKS RIGHT NOW THAT THAT --
TRY TO PREVENT PREVENT OR
PROHIBIT PERSONAL USE CAMPAIGN
FUNDS WHICH IS TRYING TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES AND WERE VERY CLOSE
THANK YOU.
AND HE IS NO WITNESSES TRAINERS
ANYTHING BRING ABOUT A COLLEGE
HER QUESTION ACCOUNT QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS A MISTER CALDERON
THEN LOOKS LIKE MISTER LOVE --
ONE THANK YOU FOR THE GUYS BUT I
ACTUALLY HAD A LONG CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY MY OFFICE -- AFTER WE
WERE DONE WITH ALL MY WORK OUR
WORK -- WITH MY CHIEF OF STAFF
OF APPARENTLY LEGISLATORS ARE
SYMPATHETIC CHARACTERS -- AND
YOU KNOW.
I LOOK AT THIS FOR AS A MULLIN
AS A MILLENNIAL THE FIRST MULLIN
ELECTED TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE
WHEN I RAN FOR OFFICE I WAS.
TWENTY FIVE AND ALL I GET.
I I WORKED -- AND ALL I COULD DO --
WHICH WAS DEVICE WAS TO GET
ALONE IN ORDER TO TO HOLD ME
OVER TO PAY FOR MY EXPENSES --
IN THE TIME THAT I NEED TO TAKE
WORK OFF TO CAMPAIGN FULL TIME
AS IT GOT CLOSER TO THE UP TO
THE ELECTION I CAN ONLY APPROVED
FOR THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
LOAN.
I AND SO IT IT IT IT EXPANDED
THE TIME THE LENGTH OF TIME.
THAT -- I HAD TO WORK WHILE MY
OPPONENTS WERE ABLE TO CONTINUE --
TO WORK -- CAMPAIGN FULL TIME I
HAD TO WORK A LITTLE BIT LONGER
HAD I BEEN IN A POSITION WHERE I
HAD KIDS AT THAT TIME.
IT WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT.
DISADVANTAGE FOR ME BECAUSE A
LOT OF THE TIMES OF THE VENTS
THAT I ATTEND EVEN OUT TODAY OF
OTHERS AS A LEGISLATOR -- ARE
PREDICATED UPON WHETHER I CAN
HAVE MY FAMILY WITH ME OR NOT --
WHETHER IT'S ATTENDING A
CONFERENCE WHETHER IT'S
ATTENDING ANYTHING -- OUR JOB
RELY ON US TO BE PLACES TO LEARN
ABOUT ISSUE AREAS TO GET THE
CONTACTS THAT WE NEED IN ORDER
TO TAKE A VOTE -- TO RENDER A
DECISION ON A VOTE WHILE ALSO AT
THE SAME TIME DEVELOP
RELATIONSHIPS ARE GONNA HELP US
MAKE MAKE US MORE SUCCESSFUL
WHEN IT COMES TO PUSHING
DIFFERENT POLICIES THAT DON'T
MATTER JUST TO US.
BECAUSE WE RAN TO RUN WE WE WE
RAN TO WORK ON CERTAIN ISSUES
BUT ALSO ISSUES THAT FACE.
CALIFORNIANS AND SO -- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW I DID
BACKWARDS -- IN A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN PEOPLE RUN HAVE KIDS THEY
HAVE THEIR OF HOUSE STATE YOU
KNOW THEY'RE ALREADY MARRIED I
WASN'T I WASN'T MARRIED AND HAVE
KIDS AT IN ON A HOME I DID ALL
THAT STUFF -- WHILE I WAS IN
OFFICE -- BUT NOW TODAY.
IT'S SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTS ME
THIS ISN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
I WOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
BUT I THINK -- THAT -- THERE ARE
A LOT OF CANDIDATES THAT ARE
DETERRED FROM RUNNING FOR OFFICE
BECAUSE OF THIS AND A LOT OF
LEGISLATORS THAT HAVE YOUNG KIDS
THAT UNDERSTAND THE DYNAMICS AT
WORK ON SEVEN MONTHS OUT OF THE
YEAR MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY.
EVERY SINGLE YEAR YOU PUT A LOT
ON YOUR SPOUSE ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOUR SPOUSE ISN'T COMING OUT
WITH YOU TO SACRAMENTO WHEN YOU
KNOW LIKE IN MY SITUATION -- MY
FAMILY'S IN LA -- EVEN THOUGH
THE WITH ME THIS WEEK WHICH IS
GREAT HAS BEEN REALLY NICE --
AND AND SO THEY'RE JUST A LOT OF
DIFFERENT DYNAMICS I GO INTO HOW
THIS COULD DETER I THINK YOUNG
PEOPLE IT ADD OUR CURRENT
POLICIES COULD COULD DETER YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE TO SEEK
OFFICE ESPECIALLY IF THEY HAVE
YOUNG KIDS -- AND SO I I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE IT ISN'T AN ISSUE IT IT IS
IN A DIFFICULT ISSUE NOT NOT
BECAUSE IT'S A DIFFICULT POLICY
TO SUPPORT THE DIFFERENT
DIFFICULT POLITICAL ISSUE TO
SUPPORT.
AGAIN BECAUSE WE'RE NOT THE
SYMPATHETIC CHARACTERS BUT I I I
I I DO APPLAUD YOU TAKING ON
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IT IMPACTS A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
ARE AND ME AND AND I THINK THAT --
WE WANT TO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ENCOURAGE -- THE BEST AND THE
BRIGHTEST ESPECIALLY THE BEST
AND BRIGHTEST FROM THE NEXT
GENERATION AND I DON'T THINK
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE A SYSTEM.
OF OF WHERE YOU HAVE CANDIDATES
THAT DON'T HAVE KIDS THAT ARE
MORE ENCOURAGED TO RUN THE
CANDIDATES THAT DO HAVE KIDS
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE YOUNG
BECAUSE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
PRESENTS BECAUSE IT'S NOT EASY.
TO DO IT IS NOT CHEAP -- AND
HAVING A LITTLE EXTRA HELP I
THINK COULD IT COULD HELP
MOTIVATE YOUNG CANDIDATES TO TO
RUN FOR OFFICE SO THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORT APPRECIATE THAT IN THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER MAJORITY LEADER.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND A LINE
MY COMMENTS ALSO WITH A MISTER
CALDERON ON ADDRESSING THE
PARITY OF THAT THIS PROVIDES --
AND JUST A CLARIFICATION ON
QUESTION JUST GIVEN THAT MISS
CAMPAIGN ATTORNEY AND TRYING TO
FIND IN OUNCES IN THE COMING
OFFICE WITH RESPECT TO THAT OF
THE FISHEL CAMPAIGN DUTIES IN
THE OFFICE HOLDER EXPENSES AS
YOU WELL KNOW -- MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE ASSEMBLY
PARTICULAR ARE UP FOR ELECTION
EVERY TWO YEARS SO.
SORT OF CAMPAIGNING NONSTOP.
ACTUALLY SO HAVING SAID THAT IS
THERE A DISTINCTION WITH RESPECT
TO THE BILL AND HAND OFFICE
HOLDOVERS OF THAT OF CAN AND IT
WAS AT ONE IN THE SAME.
I THINK THAT -- DO YOU WANT.
TO LOOK GOOD AND I'M I I THINK
THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY ONE WHAT
AT THAT AT THE KEY ISSUES THAT
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO FINE TUNE
AT THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT I
THINK YOU KNOW WITH.
WITH THE CAMPAIGN ACTIVITY.
IT'S A LITTLE MORE CLEAR WHEN
SOMETHING IS -- TEASER LEGAL
TERM BUT FOR THE CAMPAIGN
ACTIVITY YOU WOULD NOT HAVE TO
USE ARE YOU NOT HAVE -- TO USE
CHILD CARE -- FOR OFFICIAL
DUTIES -- YEP IF YOU HAVE A FULL
TIME JOB AND THEN YOU GET
ELECTED YOU HAVE ANOTHER FULL
TIME JOB.
AND SO -- YOU WERE WORKING WITH
THE F. T. P. SEAT TO FINE TUNE
THE LANGUAGE SO THAT YOU'RE NOT.
ESSENTIALLY JUST CHANGING ONE
FULL TIME JOB TO ANOTHER -- IN
USING CAMPAIGN FUNDS DURING THAT
BUT RATHER YOU KNOW WHEN -- YOU.
HOW YOU TAILOR THAT THAT'S SORT
OF WHAT WE'RE WORKING OUT RIGHT
NOW BUT BUT I?
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TACKLING AT
THE MOMENT.
YES.
I THINK THE PART OF THE AGAIN
THE THE THE INTENT LEGEND TEN AS
WELL RECOGNIZE BUT HOW DO WE
DISTINGUISH THAT OF THE OFFICE
HOLDER COUNT VERSE THAT OF THE
CAMPAIGN REELECT ACCOUNT AND MY
UNDERSTANDING YOU CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG IT'S IT'S ONE IN THE
SAME OFFICE HOLD.
ACCOUNT CAN BE USED IS THE SAME
SO WHEN IS THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THAT OF OFFICIAL DUTIES
SO.
AS OFFICIAL DUTIES I MAY AS ONE
SHOULD THIS BILL BECOME LAW.
COULD AN INDIVIDUAL OFFICEHOLDER.
USED THAT -- WALL AND OFFICIAL
CAPACITY OF THE OFFICE OR
ACCOUNT VERSUS THE DISTINCTION
OF THE CANDIDATE ACCOUNT BUT
IT'S ONE OF THE SAME RIGHT RIGHT
FROM -- I DON'T THINK WELL IT
USED TO BE IF THAT'S A REALLY
GREAT QUESTION WE HAVEN'T LOOKED
AT HOW THE IT WOULD BE YEARS
RIGHT.
YOU KNOW HOW CAMPAIGN FUNDS CAN
BE YEARS FROM THE CANDIDATE
ACCOUNT THE OFFICE HOLDER
ACCOUNT AND EVEN THE CANDIDATE
CONTROLLED BALLOT MEASURE IT
COMMITTEE ACCOUNT EACH IS
SUBJECT TO THEIR OWN ROLES SO
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING WE GO
BACK AND TALK TO THAT OF PPC.
SURE ABOUT YES MAYBE JUST.
YEAH I MEAN I I WOULD I WOULD
SAY FRANKLY IN IN CRAFTING THIS
BILL.
I WAS CONTEMPLATING THAT.
THE THE THE CAMPAIGN MONEY IN IT
BUT NOT NOT THE OFFICE HOLDER.
ACCOUNT OF HOW MANY FOLKS HAVE
BOTH -- BUT I WAS THINKING ABOUT
THE REELECTION.
I AM COMMITTEE FUNDS AND THAT
WOULD BE USED BOTH FOR A
CAMPAIGN RELATED ACTIVITY AND
FOR OFFICIAL DUTIES JUST TO MAKE
IT CLEAR IT YOU KNOW IT'S
BROUGHT IT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL YOU YOU DO HAVE
A CAMPAIGN HAD THAT YOU WEAR.
IF YOUR FACIAL DUTY HAT THEN
INTO THE EXTENT EITHER OF THOSE
HATS I REQUIRE YOU TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL CHILD CARE IT COULD
BE PAID FOR BY AIR YOUR
REELECTION COMMITTEE THAT'S THE
IDEA -- BUT YOU BASICALLY
QUESTION OF OF OF NEW WANTS THAT
WE MIGHT WANT TO ADDRESS WITH
FUTURE MA'AM JUST TO MAKE IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR I THINK IT'S
GONNA BE IMPORTANT IN THIS BILL
THIS HOPE.
THE WHOLE PURPOSE FOR THIS BILL
TO PROVIDE CLARITY.
SO THAT THERE'S GUIDANCE AND
OFFICIALS KNOW WHAT THEY CAN AND
CAN'T DO SO.
THANK YOU FOR FOR RAISING THAT
HE WANTS WILL SEEK TO ADDRESS IN
THE FUTURE YES YES THIS IS MY
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY OFFICE
HOLDER KIND OF CAMPAIGN.
LIKE HOW DOES ONE OF THE SAME
RIGHT SO OF PERHAPS THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS AND AT FOR CLARITY TO
WHICH YOU KNOW YOU'RE THE INTENT
OF THE BILL IS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THE CHIEF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER LOWE GREATNESS ROSTER.
YES SO I MEAN I KIND OF STRUGGLE
WITH THIS A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW ON THE ONE HAND.
I THINK WE ALL MAKE SACRIFICES
WE RUN FOR PUBLIC OFFICE WHETHER
WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW YOUNG KIDS ARE NOT LIKE
WE ALL HAVE PERSONAL THINGS.
THAT WE DO HAVE TO SACRIFICE YOU
KNOW TO DO THESE JOBS I DON'T
THINK THAT REALLY MAKES THIS.
ANY DIFFERENT FROM THE GENERAL
PUBLIC -- ALSO YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE JOBS THEY HAVE YOU KNOW
DEMANDING.
SCHEDULES AND OBLIGATIONS AFTER
ME.
AND GUESS WHAT THEY HAVE TO
MANAGE HOW TO FIGURE OUT CHILD
CARE AND THAT'S A BIG DISCUSSION
THAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW --
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW
HOW DO WE HELP.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WITH.
WITH THAT ISSUE AND IT IT JUST
SEEMS A LITTLE BIT LIKE WERE
KIND OF YOU KNOW WE HAVE THESE
CAMPAIGN FUNDS THAT WE REYES.
YOU KNOW -- EARLY TO HELP OUR
ELECTION EFFORTS -- YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE GIVING US.
DONATIONS YOU KNOW BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE IN YOU AS A CANDIDATE
AND I WANT TO HELP YOU GET
ELECTED.
AND SO YOU KNOW PRIMARILY THAT'S
THE IDEAS HEY THAT'S FOR
ELECTIONEERING THINGS NOW CAN I
SEE THAT.
HEY AND LOOK I HAVE FIVE YOUNG
CHILDREN.
IT'S HARD NOT TO TAKE MYSELF
PERSONALLY OUT OF THIS RIGHT --
I CAN'T AFFORD A NANNY -- BUT WE
HAVE WE WE DEFINITELY IS A LOT
OF BABY SITTERS AND AND PROBABLY
MY BABY SITTING.
MY OUT OF MY BUDGET IS PRETTY
HIGH HIGHER THAN A MAYBE LIKE IT
TO BE -- BUT YOU KNOW COULD I
SEE THAT A DONOR MAYBE IS LIKE
OH HEY YOU KNOW AND HELPING YOU.
I CAN MAYBE ALSO HELP YOU AS
YOU'RE OUT CAMPAIGNING YOU KNOW
HELPING WITH WITH CHILD CARE
YEAH PROBABLY MOST MY DOLLARS
AND SAVE.
I DON'T REALLY CARE ABOUT THAT
THAT MUCH RIGHT -- BUT BUT THE
SAME TIME AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE JOBS I GOT TO
GO TO AN ANDIN A LESSER
ELIGIBLE FOR A PROGRAM NOBODY'S
PAYING FOR THEIR CHILD CARE.
YOU KNOW AND THEY DON'T HAVE A
FUND. TO HELP THEM PAY FOR THEIR
CHILD CARE -- SO FROM THAT
CIRCUMSPECT THAT FEEL LIKE ARE
WE KIND OF MAKING OURSELVES A
LITTLE BIT SPECIAL.
IN THAT CASE -- AND AND I GET
THE GENDER PARITY ISSUE.
BUT YEAH THERE'S ALSO THEIR
SINGLE DADS THE OTHERS MARRIED
MARRIED COUPLES THAT STRUGGLE TO
FIGURE OUT CHILD CARE -- TO IT'S
NOT JUST.
YOU KNOW ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE AND
AGAIN ALL OF US HAVE DIFFERENT
ISSUES AND PERSONAL EXPENSES.
THAT WE INCUR DOING THESE JOBS
SO WHY SHOULD WE CORDON OFF ONE
THING SO I STRUGGLE WITH THAT
PART A LITTLE BIT -- BUT THEN I
THINK THE SECOND PART IS IT
DOESN'T IS GET A LITTLE BIT
MESSY RIGHT BECAUSE HOW DO WE
DETERMINE LIKE OKAY THIS CHILD
CARE WAS FOR A CAMPAIGN EVENT.
AS OPPOSED TO I'M JUST PAYING
YOUR CHILD CARE BILL.
YOU KNOW FOR THE FULL YEAR
EVERYBODY HAS CHILD CARE THAT
THEY YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW WELL
MAYBE NOT EVERYBODY BUT
EVERYBODY HAS CHILD CARE
EXPENSES OR A PARENT IS SPENDING
A LOT OF TIME.
TAKING OVER THAT ROLE AND IT'S
NOT AS AS I CAN PERSONALLY
ATTEST IS NOT AN EASY ROLE TO
FILL.
EVERYBODY'S DOING THAT IN SOME --
CIRCUMSTANCE -- ARE WE GOING TO
USE CAMPAIGN FUNDS TO COVER WHAT
WOULD BE YOUR BASIC CHILD CARE.
FUNDS BASIC CHILDCARE EXPENSES
JUST AS THEY WOULD BE EVEN IF
YOU WEREN'T ELECTED -- OR IS IT
ONLY FOR THE CAMPAIGN SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'RE SAYING IT'S ONLY.
FOR LEGITIMATE CAMPAIGN RELATED.
EXPENSES BUT THEN WHEN YOU GO ON
AUDIT THAT HOW DO YOU HOW TO HOW
DOES ONE DIFFERENTIATE THAT -- I
THINK THAT COULD BE KIND OF
MESSY AND DIFFICULT IN THE COULD
MAYBE MUDDY THE WATERS THE EVEN
MORE SO.
ARE THESE THIS IS WHAT I'M KIND
OF STRUGGLING TO CONCEIVE ON
BOTH SIDES BUT I THINK THERE IS
SOME DIFFICULTY THERE.
WE GRAY POINTED OUT.
DIDN'T IT JUST BROKE REAL
BRIEFLY I APPRECIATE YOUR POINTS
YOU KNOW AM AND I'VE GIVEN
THOUGHT TO IT TO EACH OF THEM.
AND YOU KNOW IT'S ELECTED
OFFICIALS WITH CAMPAIGN ACCOUNTS
IT IT'S IT'S A YOU IT'S A UNIQUE
[inaudible]
I AM.
IN A PART OF FUNDS THAT ARE THAT
ARE UNIQUE TO ELECTED OFFICIALS
RAN FOR OFFICE NOT AT NIGHT WHEN
HOUSING I AGREE -- BUT IT'S NOT
JUST FREE MONEY I MEET YOUR YOUR
YOUR REACHING OUT YOUR TO YOUR
YOUR POTENTIAL DONORS YOUR LOVE
ONES YOUR SUPPORTERS THAT YOU'RE
RAISING IT.
AND THEY WANT YOU TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL LOOK AT OFFICIAL IT
MEANS BEING OUT ON AS YOU KNOW
NIGHTS AND WEEKENDS AND AWAY
FROM YOUR FAMILY -- AND THEY
WHITE THEIR BEST AND YOU TO BE
SUCCESSFUL THE REPRESENT THEM TO
THE BEST OF YOUR ABILITY.
SO I CAN'T GET THE MIND OF EVERY
DONOR -- THAT THAT WOULD
CONTRIBUTE TO CAMPAIGN FINE BUT
I I THINK GENERALLY THEY BELIEVE
IN.
THE CANDIDATE THE SUPPORTING AND
WHAT THAT PERSON BE SUCCESSFUL
IN.
A TO ACCEPT BEARS TO REMOVE TO
MAKE THEM ABOUT ELECTED
OFFICIALS I THINK THEY WOULD.
SUPPORT THAT AND YOU KNOW THAT
THE HORSE IS ALREADY LEFT A
STABLE BOTH AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
AND THE STATE LEVEL ON WHETHER
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE CAMPAIGN
EXPENSE IT'S IT'S CLEARLY
APPROPRIATE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
CONGRESS PEOPLE CAN DO THIS NOW --
DOESN'T VICE LETTER -- THAT SAID
YOU CAN DO IT AT THE STATE LEVEL.
BUT AS A MISS MOBY INDICATED
THAT'S THAT'S NOT SUFFICIENT
AUTHORITY WE WANT TO BE MORE
CLEAR.
SAID IS NOT A LOT OF DEBATE ON
WHETHER IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
EXPENSE WERE JUST TRYING TO GET
THE THE ADDITIONAL CLARITY AND
AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THIS
WILL CERTAINLY INCREASE GENDER
PARITY.
BUT NOT ONLY GENDER PARITY IT'LL
IT'LL POP UP PROVIDE ENOUGH
THREE FOR MORE PARENTS TO BE AN
OFFICE AND THAT'S A GREAT THING.
WHEN I WAS FIRST RUNNING FOR
CITY COUNCIL I SAW A LOT OF
RETIRED FOLKS OF FOLKS THAT
WITHOUT KIDS -- WEALTHIER FOLKS
AND I SAID WERE YOU KNOW I THINK
IT BECAUSE THERE IS A DOWN ON
THAT COUNCIL WITH YOUNG KIDS WHO
WHO I WAS.
IN IT I BROUGHT A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON AS WE REYES GET
TO MAKE IT POLICIES THAT AFFECT
FAMILIES WITH KIDS AND AND AND
AND OUR CHILDREN EVERY DAY AND
IT AND TO HAVE OUR OWN KIDS AND
HAVE THE EXPERIENCE I THINK
MAKES US BETTER POLICY MAKERS.
IT'S OUR LIVED EXPERIENCES THAT
WE CAN BRING TO THE TABLE WHEN
WE MAKE POLICY DECISIONS.
AND ON YOUR LAST POINT THAT'S
EXACTLY THE ISSUE THAT MISTER
THAT THE CHURCH ARE BERMAN IS
HAS REYES WITH US TACTIC PROVIDE
CLARITY.
ON A WHAT IS DIRECTLY RELATED
AND WHAT ISN'T IF YOU'RE ALREADY
PAYING FOR CHILDCARE BEFORE YOU
EVER RUN FOR OFFICE AND THEN YOU
START RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
YOU OUGHT NOT BE ABLE TO USE
YOUR YOUR CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR
WHAT YOU HAVE ALREADY DONE
BEFORE YOU START RUNNING FOR
OFFICE BUT IF YOU'RE FROM THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND YOU COME
UP TO SACRAMENTO FORTIES WE CAN
YOU NEED TO GET ADDITIONAL CHILD
CARE TO MAKE IT WORK FOR YOUR
FAMILY -- TIP TO PERFORM
OFFICIAL DUTIES THAT PROBABLY
CAN'T AND WE WANT TO PUT THE
LANGUAGE IN HERE THAT WILL HELP
CAPTURE THAT.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE LINE IS
DRAWN AT THERE IS CLARITY FOR
ENFORCING AND FOR AUDITING AND
FOR EVERYTHING ELSE SO WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA WORK ON THAT IN.
A CHAIR BERMAN HAS GIVEN
INSTRUCTION TO DO THAT WE WILL.
THIS MESSAGE.
I THINK I DO NOT HAVE CHILDREN --
SO THIS THERE IS NO -- CONFLICT
FOR ME IS NOT LIKE HEY THIS BE
GREAT TO BE ABLE TO OF TO HAVE
CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR FOR CHILD
CARE BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE ANY
CHILDREN -- BUT I CAN SEE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT SITUATIONS.
IN WHICH THE LINE IS ALREADY
BLURRED -- BUT IMAGINE I'M IF
YOU'RE OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL --
AND YOU'VE GOT CAMPAIGN STAFF
THAT ARE WORKING FOR YOU AND
YOU'VE GOT SOME OF THAT AND YOU
SAY HEY CAN YOU WATCH MY
CHILDREN AND FOR AN HOUR WATCH
MY CHILDREN FOR TWO HOURS.
I'M SURE THAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING -- TODAY -- AND THERE
NEEDS TO BE CLARITY AND SO I'M
I'M THANKFUL FOR YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS THIS FORD -- I
THINK IT MAKES ABSOLUTE --
ABSOLUTE SENSE AND THERE IS.
AN INCREDIBLE COST TO RUNNING
FOR FOR POLITICAL OFFICE -- AND
THERE ARE SOME -- WHO ARE
MARRIED BUT THEY HAVE CHILDREN
AND YOU HAVE ONE SPOUSE THEY CAN
WATCH AT THE CHILD YOU'VE GOT
OTHERS THEIR SINGLE PARENTS ON
THE DON'T HAVE THAT ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT?
I DO THINK THAT THAT PROVIDE
SOME SOME PARITY SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL A TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER MASON.
BUT WEBER.
I WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR THE
CONVERSATION -- I'M NOT SURE HOW
I FEEL ABOUT THIS I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY AND ONLY
BECAUSE YEAH I FEEL LIKE I'VE
BEEN A PROFESSIONAL MY WHOLE
LIFE AND I'VE HAD CHILDREN AND
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND THEY WERE MY RESPONSIBILITY --
I NEVER FELT THAT OF THE ANYBODY --
SHOULD PAY FOR MUCH SHOP HERE.
OF WHEN I WENT TO WORK OR EVEN
WHEN I CAMPAIGN BECAUSE THAT'S
ALL PART OF A JOB AND SO.
I'M NOT SURE IF SOMETIMES WE TRY
TO TAKE ON TOO MUCH WITHOUT
REALIZING THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR MALES AND
FEMALES IN THE AREA SHOP YEAR
PERIOD.
AND IT'S NOT AN EASY TASK AND I
STRUGGLE EVERY DAY WITH MY STAFF
WHO CAN'T AFFORD SHOP HERE.
AND I'M ASKING THEM TO DO THINGS
AT NIGHT.
ON WEEKENDS YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO AND AND MANY
OF THEM DON'T FALL INTO THE
CATEGORY EVEN DOING THE REGULAR
DAY IF THEY QUALIFY. FOR FOR OUR
SUBSIDIES AND FREE YOU KNOW KIND
OF REDUCE CHOP HERE SO I HAVE I
HAVE.
YOUNG STAFF THAT STRUGGLES IN
THE DISTRICT OFFICE WITH WITH
THE ISSUE OF CHOP HERE -- AND
AND WE'VE TRIED VARIOUS WAYS OF
CHANGING THE FORMULA HERE AND A
WHOLE LOT OF THINGS SO.
IT YOUR JOB IS A BIG ISSUE IN
THE STATE AND I'M NOT SURE IF
GIVING US LACK IS THAT GOOD
BECAUSE WE MAKE MORE THAN MOST
OF THE FOLKS WHO STRUGGLING
WHICH OUT HERE.
AT THE BECAUSE IT IS IN BETWEEN
GROUP OF FORTY TO FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR THEY CAN'T AFFORD
YOU KNOW TO DUBBED DON'T GET IN
THE PRE SCHOOL SET OF SUBSIDIZED.
THEY DON'T GET IN SOMETHING ELSE
AND SO THEY'RE REALLY STRUGGLING
WITH CHILD HERE SO I'M I'M NOT
REALLY SURE ABOUT THIS I KNOW IN --
AND I HOPE IT DOESN'T GO INTO
THE SLIPPERY SLOPE OF EVERYTHING
THAT TURNS OUT TO BE THAT'S
SOMEWHAT RELATED THAT WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING.
FOR WE WERE STRUGGLING WITH NOW
OF A CANDIDATE NOT A CANDIDATE
BUT A AN OF CONGRESSMAN IN SAN
DIEGO WHO HAS PAID FOR
EVERYTHING -- YOU KNOW TUITIONS
AND THIS AND THIS AND THAT.
AND SO AS A RESULT HE'S JUST
KIND OF ABUSE THE SYSTEM IN THE
WORST KIND OF WAY BUT YET HE
ARGUES THAT THIS IS A PART OF
HIS WOULD BE AS A DO BECAUSE HE
GOES TO WASHINGTON.
AND HIS KIDS NEED TO BE IN A
PRIVATE SCHOOL THE SECURED BLAH
BLAH BLAH.
SO YOU KNOW.
SO WE PLATE THE STATE OF MEAN
THEY PAID I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS THOUSAND
AND PRIVATE SCHOOL JOB HERE FOR
HIS CHILDREN.
AND THE END AND SO THAT'S GOOD
AND IT'S BEING LITIGATED IN THIS
BOOK OF THE BIBLE IN UP IN JAIL
BUT THAT AS WELL AS A HOST OF
OTHER THINGS.
SO I JUST I'M JUST HOPEFUL THAT
SOMEONE OF YOUR PRIVATE SOME
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THIS
IS IMPLEMENTED.
AND WHAT OUR RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE AS AS AS AS JUST PEOPLE WHO
LIVE AND WORK EVERY DAY -- IT IS
NOT EASY TO HAVE CHILDREN IT IS
NOT EASY TO HAVE TO OF FOR
CHOPPY AND CHOP HIS BECOME EVEN
MORE EXPENSIVE.
EVERY DAY FOR MOST FOLKS SO.
YOU KNOW AND AND AND AND I AND I
AGREE THAT THE AVERAGE CITIZEN
DOESN'T GET THE BENEFIT OF IT
AND I KNOW WHEN I WAS ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD.
WE HAVE PARENTS WHO CAME ALL THE
AND THE MAIN ISSUE WAS CHILDCARE
CHILDCARE CHILD.
I HAD THE SAME ISSUE I WAS A
YOUNG WITH AT THE TIME ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD I HAD CHOPPY ISSUES
TOO BUT I FIGURED OUT YOU KNOW
AND I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
ANYBODY ELSE'S JOB TO FIGURE IT
OUT.
SO THAT I COULD COME TO SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS I DO THINGS AT
NIGHT THAT I HAD TO I HAD TO
FIGURE IT OUT MYSELF I HAD AND
MY HUSBAND HAD FIGURED OUT HE
WAS VERY ACTIVE IN SO WE
TRAVELED A LOT BUT THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS A PART.
OF OUR LIFE IT BECAME AN EXPENSE
SO I I'M I'M I'M COME IN AND AND
BILL.
AND AMBIVALENT WITH REGARD TO
THIS I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT BUT
I'M HOPING THAT.
THERE'S SOME CLARITY THAT COMES
IN THAT MAKES SENSE FOR IT SO
THAT WE DON'T END UP WITH THIS.
THIS THIS SELF FEELING THAT UP --
WE HAVE TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALL OF THESE ISSUES THAT FOLKS
HAVE.
ARE AND AND AND YET AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE NOT SENSITIVETO THE
TO THE SAME ISSUES OF FOLKS WHO
MAKE LOT LESS THAN WE DO.
WE HAVE MORE RESPONSIBILITY
SOMETIMES AND WE DO AND THIS
STRUGGLING EVERY DAY THAT MAKE
SHOP HERE WORK FOR THEM WHY THEY
TRY TO GO TO JOBS.
AND THAT AREN'T AS LUCRATIVE AS
OURS ARE SO I MEAN I'M REAL
SENSITIVE TO THAT BECAUSE YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE THAT
SPECIAL -- MAYBE WE ARE BUT IN
TERMS OF GETTING -- YOU KNOW
SOMETHING ELSE THAT SUPPORTS
THAT SHOP HERE WHILE WE'RE
CAMPAIGNING AND DOING OTHER
KINDS OF THINGS AND AND WHAT
HAVE YOU SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
IT TODAY BUT I'M HOPING THERE'S
SOME.
CLARITY COMES OUT OF THE
DISCUSSION WITH THE F. PPC FOLKS
AND OTHERS.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO EITHER
REALLY GOOD POINT IS ALWAYS
DOCKED WEBER AND JUST TO CLARIFY
ONE SMALL POINT THAT YOU THAT
YOU REFERENCED I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT PRIVATE SCHOOL
TUITION IS NOT AN AUTHORIZED.
CAN WE CONFIRM WHAT ARE THE
AMENDMENTS.
THERE AREN'T ANY AMENDMENTS TO
THE THE THE EXISTING BILL THE
AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO KEEP ON
WORKING WITH THE F. B. PC THAT
ADDITIONAL -- CAM A CLARITY TO A
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WOULD BE
ALLOWED WHAT WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
TO YOU KNOW DEVELOP FURTHER THE
THE THE SITUATIONS WHERE A
CANDIDATE OR AN OFFICE HOLDER
WOULD BE ABLE TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES.
OF THIS OPPORTUNITY THE ONE ATTY
MORE CLARITY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH WE MISTER CALDERON IT IS
TOWARDS THE END OF THE BILL IF
YOU HAVE THE BILL IN PRINT IT'S
SECTION H. WANTED TO KIND OF
CLARIFY IS WHAT'S INCLUDED IN
AUTHORIZED HEALTHCARE EXPENSES
WHAT'S NOT.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
CAN KEEP ON WORKING ON WE WILL
BE OUR THANKS TO THE DISCUSSION
IS SUPER HELPFUL JUST REAL QUICK
AND LOOK AT I THINK ONE ISSUE
MIGHT JUST BE THE PERFORMING
OFFICIAL DUTIES AND MAYBE AT
SOME WE CAN TALK ABOUT FURTHER.
IS BECAUSE YEAH WE'RE DOING A
JOB.
JUST LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE HAS TO
DO A JOB TO AND THEY HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET.
YOU KNOW THE CHILD CARE.
TAKING CARE OF AS WELL -- YOU
KNOW IF IT'S DM SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO A CAMPAIGN ACTIVITY I
HAVE TO BE HERE BECAUSE I'M
CAMPAIGNING FOR OFFICE I THINK
THAT'S MORE AND MAYBE AND MORE
UNDERSTANDABLE BUT MAY FOR HEY
WE'RE JUST DOING THE JOB THAT.
WE SIGNED UP TO DO.
I THINK THAT KIND OF PUTS US IN
THAT PLACE OF WOULD JUST YOU
KNOW YEAH WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
UNIQUE JOB BUT EVERYBODY HAS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO I THINK
KIND OF LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO SAID EVERYBODY HAS TO
FIGURE THAT OUT -- AND WE DON'T
NECESSARILY PROVIDE THIS FOR YOU
KNOW FOR FOLKS IN THAT SITUATION
YOU KNOW SO.
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT I WOULD BE
LOOKING FOR I THINK IS WEEK AS
THIS WERE TO MOVE FORWARD.
WORK ON THAT.
WHICH ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU FOR DISCUSSION
SUPER HELPFUL WE HAVE OUR OUR
OUR OUR HOMEWORK TO DO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS TO MAKE
IT CLEAR AND BETTER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WELL I I APPRECIATE THE THE
CONVERSATION WITH MY COLLEAGUES
WHICH I ALWAYS DO -- ALSO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS
TO ENCOURAGE GREATER DIVERSITY
AMONG CANDIDATES FOR ELECTIVE
OFFICE BY SEEKING TO ADDRESS ONE
POTENTIAL AND DIVERSITIES GENDER
DIVERSITY IT CAN ALSO BE YOUNGER.
DAD'S SINGLE THAT YOU KNOW IT IS
JUST DIVERSITY IT'S IT'S NOT
YOUR TYPICAL ELECTED OFFICIAL --
WHICH I ALSO EXPERIENCE WHEN I
WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL AS THE
YOUNGEST PERSON BY TWENTY YEARS --
THE SO THAT YOU KNOW ENCOURAGING
GREATER DIVERSITY AMONG
CANDIDATES FOR ELECTIVE OFFICE.
BY SEEKING TO ADDRESS ONE
POTENTIAL BARRIER TO INDIVIDUALS
SEEKING PUBLIC OFFICE.
AT THE SAME TIME IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE MAINTAIN PROTECTIONS
AGAINST CAMPAIGN FUNDS BEING
CONVERTED TO PERSONAL USE -- SO
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH F. PPC AND COMMITTEE STAFF
TO FURTHER DEFINE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH CHILD
CARE EXPENSES ARE DEEMED. TO
HAVE RESULTED FROM CAMPAIGN
ACTIVITIES OR OFFICIAL DUTIES --
AND WITH THAT COMMITMENT I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE ON THE
BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I'D GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING CALDERON.
CALDERON I'D LOW LOW AYE MAYES.
MAYES HI MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THAT IS OUT ON A SIX TWO ZERO
VOTING RESOLUTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I CAN HEAR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
I'M GONNA HAND OVER THE REINS TO
THE VICE CHAIR THE GOOD NEWS IS
WERE WE'RE HALFWAY THROUGH THE
AGENDA AND WE HAVE TWO VERY.
EASY SIMPLE QUICK BILLS.
LAUGHS OF THEIR MIND
.
IT'S A GOOD ONE OKAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- YOU HAVE. TWO BILLS
I GUESS RIGHT.
WE'LL START WITH AB SIX NINETY
THREE SINCE I GOT A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
LET'S DO THAT GO AHEAD THERE'S
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES.
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
ALSO KNOWN AS SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION.
IS A SAFETY NET FOR CALIFORNIANS
WHO MISSED THE DEADLINE TO
REGISTER TO VOTE OR UPDATE THEIR
REGISTRATION.
CURRENTLY A CONDITIONAL VOTER IS
GIVEN A PROVISIONAL BALLOT WHICH
IS PROCESS AFTER ELECTION DAY
DURING THE CAMPUS PERIOD.
THIS PROCESS WAS ESTABLISHED
BEFORE VOTE CAL CALIFORNIA'S
STATEWIDE VOTER DATABASE WAS
CERTIFIED.
USING VOCALIC COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL IS NOW ABLE TO VERIFY
IF VOTERS ELIGIBLE IMMEDIATELY
AND UPDATE THE DATABASE IN REAL
TIME.
THIS MEANS THAT THE SAME PROCESS
TO VERIFY A CONDITIONAL
REGISTRANT ELIGIBILITY THAT
CURRENTLY OCCURS ON THE BACKEND
AFTER THE ELECTION AFTER
ELECTION DAY.
CAN SIMPLY HAPPEN ON THE FRONT
AND INSTEAD IN REAL TIME.
THEREFORE A. B. SIX NINETY THREE
WOULD AUTHORIZE AN ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL TO OFFER A NON
PROVISIONAL OR REGULAR BALLOT TO
A CONDITIONALLY REGISTERED VOTER
IF THE OFFICIAL USES VOEPEL. TO
DETERMINE THE VOTERS ELIGIBLE.
VERIFY THE PERSON HAS NOT VOTED
CHECK IF THEY ARE INCLUDED ON A
ROSTER IN ANY OTHER COUNTY.
AN UPDATE THE VOTE COUNT RECORD
TO INDICATE THE PERSON HAS VOTED.
IF THOSE CONDITIONS ARE NOT MET
THEN THE VOTER WILL STILL BE
ISSUED A PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE THE VOTER
EXPERIENCE REDUCE WAIT TIMES AND
LOWER THE NUMBER PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS THAT NEED TO BE
PROCESSED AFTER ELECTION DAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME IS PHILIP CHANTRY
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
OF COURTS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M PHILIP
CHANTRY.
AFTER COUNTY ELECTIONS MANAGER
AND LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE MEMBER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK CHAIRMAN
FOR OFFERING THIS BILL AND ARE
EXCITED TO SPONSOR OF THE
LANGUAGE WITHIN.
AB SIX NINETY THREE WILL PERMIT
COUNTIES TO OFFER REGULAR
BALLOTS TO CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRANTS UNDER SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY ELECTIONS
RAPIDLY APPROACHING THIS CHANGE
WILL ALLOW ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
IMMEDIATELY ADJUDICATE
CONDITIONALLY REGISTERED VOTERS
AND WILL GREATLY REDUCE THE MANY
CONDITIONALLY REGISTERED VOTERS.
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS THAT WOULD
NEED TO BE REVIEWED PROCESS AND
EDUCATED DURING THE CAMPUS
PERIOD. FOR ONLY THOSE COUNTIES
THAT HAVE UNINTERRUPTED ACCESS
TO THE STATE WIDE REGISTRATION
DATABASE AND THEIR POLLING
PLACES SATELLITE OFFICES OR VOTE
CENTERS.
UNDER THIS SPONSORED LEGISLATION
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO ENSURE THE
VOTER IS ELIGIBLE TO REGISTER.
MAKE SURE THAT THE VOTER HAS NOT
VOTED ALREADY IN ANY OTHER
COUNTY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CHECK THAT THE VOTER DOES NOT
APPEAR ON THE ROSTER INDEX OF A
COUNTY THAT DOES NOT HAVE VOTE
CENTERS.
AND MARK THE VOTER IN THE
STATEWIDE DATABASE INSTANTLY AS
HAVING VOTED.
BY FOLLOWING THIS PROCEDURE
HAVING THE VOTERS BALLOT AND
REGISTRATION IMMEDIATELY
ADJUDICATED AND COUNTED AND
INCLUDING THEIR VOTES IN THE
ELECTION NIGHT RESULTS.
WE WOULD BE CREATING A BETTER
VOTING EXPERIENCE FOR THE VOTER
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF BALLOTS
BEING ADJUDICATED.
AND PROCESS AFTER ELECTION DAY
SPEEDING UP RESULTS AND REDUCING
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON OUR
ALREADY STRESSED CAMPUS
PROCESSES AND TIME LINES.
I SHOULD AND WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY HOWEVER THAT IF THERE'S
THE SLIGHTEST AMBIGUITY ABOUT A
VOTER. FOR COMMUNICATION WITH
THE STATEWIDE DATABASE IS
INTERRUPTED AT ANY TIME.
THAT THE VOTERS BALLOT WOULD BE
PLACED IN SEALED IN AN ENVELOPE
AS THERE AS THE CURRENT
PROVISIONAL PROCESS IS FOR
ADJUDICATION LATER WHEN WE CAN
CONFIRM THE VOTERS ELIGIBILITY
TO VOTE.
I GREATLY APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
DIALOGUE AND AMENDMENTS CHAIR
BERMAN OFFICE HAS HAD WITH US IN
ORDER TO CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE CA CEO
OR DOES PASSAGE AND IS A STRONG
SUPPORTER.
AND SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BRINGS TO YOUR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
COMPOSITION YESTERDAY STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE SHAMAN THE LONG ON BEHALF
SECRETARY STATE ALEX BUT THE AND
SUPPORT.
I'M REYES LEBRON OF THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT AS AMENDED.
OKAY IN ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS CALLING BRITAIN I'M
WITH THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
AND I'D LIKE TO READ WITH.
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA OPPOSES A. B. SIX
NINETY THREE CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION VOTING.
AS AMENDED AS OF THE DATE OF
THIS LETTER WHICH WAS MARCH THE
TWENTY THIRD.
AB SIX NINETY THREE WOULD
FACILITATE A ROMANCE
REGISTRATIONS AND ENSURE THAT
INELIGIBLE VOTE.
COULD BE CAST IN AND COUNTED
WHEN A REGISTERED THE APPLICANT
APPLIES TO VOTE THE AFFIDAVIT
MUST BE VERIFIED NOT ONLY FOR
DUPLICATE CATION.
BUT ALSO FOR LEGITIMACY OF
PROVIDED ID AND DOMICILE.
AB SIX NINETY THREE WOULD
PROVIDE FOR INSTANT ACCEPTANCE
OF AN APPLICATION BASED SOLELY
UPON WHETHER OR NOT.
THAT APPLICANT IS REFLECTED ON
VOTE CAL CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
VOTER DATABASE.
THIS IS CLEARLY INSUFFICIENT
VERIFICATION OF AN APPLICATION
L. ELIGIBILITY TO VOTE.
THE PROCESS PUT PUT IN PLACE FOR
VOTER REGISTRATION CANNOT BE
SAFELY SHORT CUT OR SUBVERTED
WITHOUT IN CALCULABLE AN
IRREPARABLE DAMAGE. TO THE
INTEGRITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTIONS.
FURTHERMORE VOTE CAL IS RICK IS
RIDDLED WITH IMPERFECTIONS AND
IS AND IS NOT A RELIABLE
REFERENCE TO DETERMINE AN
APPLICANT'S ELIGIBILITY TO VOTE.
WITHOUT FURTHER INVESTIGATION.
THE E. I. P. R. C. A. DATA TEAM
HAS DONE EXHAUSTIVE RESEARCH
INTO VOTE CAL AND HAS DETERMINED
THAT IS DEEPLY FLAWED.
IT WAS IMPLEMENTED PRECIPITOUSLY
WITHOUT PROPER TESTING AND WILL
TAKE MANY YEARS TO MATURE. FOR
EXAMPLE USING THE VOTE CAL DATA
FOR LA COUNTY.
IN FEBRUARY SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN E. IPCA DATA TEAM
REVEALED THAT. SIX THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVEN SETS OF VOTERS
LIKELY REGISTERED MORE THAN ONCE
AT THE SAME ADDRESS THIS
INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT REGISTERED THREE TIMES AND
FIFTEEN REGISTERED FOUR TO FIVE
TIMES.
AT THE SAME ADDRESS. SEVEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT CENTS A VOTERS LIKELY
REGISTERED AT TWO DIFFERENT
ADDRESSES IN LA.
AND THAT INCLUDES A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR REGISTERED THREE
TIMES AT DIFFERENT ADDRESSES.
REGISTERED VOTERS IN BOTH LA AND
SENATE SAN DIEGO COUNTY INCLUDED
EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINE SETS.
AND PUT LA IN ORANGE COUNTY FIVE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN IN KERN
COUNTY.
THIRTY SEVEN REGISTERED IN BOTH
LA AND RIVERSIDE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY REGISTERED IN BOTH LA
AND SAN BERNADINE OUT ONE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO VOTERS.
REGISTERED IN BOTH LA COUNTY AND
SANTA BARBARA.
FORTY TWO REGISTERED IN BOTH LA
COUNTY AND VENTURA TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE ALSO
200-200-0400 AND THIRTY SIX
LIKELY DC VOTERS IN LA COUNTY.
50% WHO HAD DIED WITHIN THE
COUNTY WERE STILL I HAD NOT BEEN
IDENTIFIED AND REMOVED FROM THE
VOTER ROLLS.
ON VOTE CAL DATABASE.
BESIDES BEING CHAOTIC AND ON
MAINTAINED VOTE CAL IS ALSO
MISSING IMPORTANT INFORMATION.
NEEDED TO DETERMINE THE VOTER
ELIGIBILITY AND DISTINGUISH ONE
APPLICATION FROM ANOTHER.
USING THE SAME VOTE CAL LAST A
ET I SEE A DATA ANALYST
IDENTIFIED. SIXTY NINE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY LA COUNTY
REGISTRANTS WITH NO ACCURATE
DATE OF BIRTH.
NOT USE ME [inaudible] NINE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO LA COUNTY REGISTRANTS
WITH MISSING FIRST NAMES.
AND SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN LA
COUNTY REGISTRANTS WITH MISSING
LAST NAMES.
APART FROM PROPOSING UNWISE
RELIANCE ON VOTE CAL.
AB SIX NINETY THREE DOES NOT
INCLUDE WHO WOULD BE MAKING
ALEXIAN DAY DECISIONS.
VERIFICATION CANNOT BE GAINED BY
JUST A SIMPLE ONE STEP QUERY.
EVEN USING ADVANCED PROGRAMS
FUZZY LOGIC AND TRAINED
PROFESSIONAL ANALYSIS.
GETTING RELIABLE INFORMATION
FROM VOTE CAL IS DIFFICULT AS
WELL AS TIME AND LABOR INTENSIVE
WORK.
NOR DOES AB SIXTY THREE INCLUDE.
INDICATE HOW ELECTION DAY
DECISIONS WOULD BE MADE.
THERE IS NO MENTION OF SEARCH
CRITERIA TO BE USED.
DATE OF BIRTH AND NAMES ARE
QUESTIONABLE CRITERIA GIVEN THAT
VOEPEL.
HAS BEEN SHOWN TO THE JURY.
WE HAVE A COPY OF THIS LETTER
ENTIRE LETTER IN FRONT OF US
YEAH WE DO WE DO HAVE THE LETTER
SO IF IF YOU.
COULD WRAP UP OKAY OUT AND SHIP
YOUR LAST LAST PARAGRAPH IS.
ALL QUALIFIED ROSE.
REGISTRANTS -- DESERVED TO CAST
A VOTE AND HAVE IT COUNTED.
THEY ALSO DESERVE A VOTE WITHIN
THE SYSTEM THAT PROTECTS THEIR
VOTE FROM BEING DILUTED.
BY HASTILY ACCEPTED VOTES THAT
MAY NOT BE A LEGITIMATE.
LAST MINUTE REGISTRATIONS
REGISTRANTS MUST BE SUBJECT TO
THE SAME LEVEL OF SCRUTINY THAT
ALL OTHERS.
AND UNTIL PROPER PROCEDURES CAN
BE FOLLOWED THEY MUST BE ALLOWED
TO CAST ONLY PROVISIONAL BALLOTS
OKAY THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
SO I MILES LATER KNICKERBOCKER
FROM YELLOW COUNTY HERE TO
OPPOSE A. B. SIX NINETY THREE ON
BEHALF OF ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M JUST GOING TO BRIEFLY
REITERATE THE MAIN POINTS.
VOTE CALLOUS SHOWN IT DOESN'T
HAVE ENOUGH VERIFICATION POINTS
MANAGES FORWARD IS TAKING NAME
IN OPPOSITION OR THE AUTOS OKAY
AS I DO OPPOSE I THINK THAT TO
YOU.
GIVEN THE FACT THEIR SONS
INSUFFICIENT VERIFICATION ALL
ACTION DAY.
OF THESE A. B. NINETY THREE
SHOULD NOT BE ACCEPTED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- I'VE SEEN NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION.
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS.
GOOD YES MISTER MAYES.
OBVIOUSLY OF BELL.
INTEGRITY AND WITHIN OUR
ELECTION SYSTEM IS -- IS
PARAMOUNT FOR THE THE PUBLIC TO
HAVE TRUSTS -- THAT BOMB THAT.
THEIR VOTE COUNTS I'M IS -- IN
AND THAT THOSE WHO SPOKE
SHOULDN'T BE ADDED IN IS IS IS.
PARAMOUNT TO MAKING SURE THAT
OUR DEMOCRACY IS IS SOUND.
SO IN REGARDS TO THAT QUESTION
OF OF FRAUD -- GET YOU CAN YOU
DRESS THAT IS THIS GOING TO
TIGHTEN THINGS UP AS A COLUSA
MADE THERE THERE'S ABOUT A FEW
GOOD POINTS ALTHOUGH I I DO KNOW
THAT EVERY TIME I SEE THESE --
THINGS WITH THE YOU SEE SOME
IRREGULARITIES THAT HAPPEN
THEY'RE VERY THEY'RE THE GRAND
SCHEME OF THINGS WITH OF THE
MILLIONS OF VOTERS -- THAT WE DO
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA HAVING JUST A
FEW OF THESE -- YOU KNOW I'M NOT
SURE MAKES THAT MAKES THE CASE
BUT I AM CONCERNED THAT.
THERE COULD BE SOME FRAUD -- THE
THAT'S THANK YOU DRESS THAT.
SURE -- THE COURT OF THE DAY
IT'S GOING TO BE I HAVE A THIRTY
FIVE FOOT FLAG POLE IN MY FRONT
YARD SO I TAKE THIS EXTREMELY
SERIOUSLY I'VE GOT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
WORKING IN ELECTIONS -- I TEND
TO GET CHOKED UP WHEN I TALK
ABOUT THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT
ELECTION OFFICIALS HAVE.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE PROCESS
PROCESSES IN COUNTIES THAT ARE
CONNECTED TO THE STATEWIDE
DATABASE THAT THIS BILL PROPOSES
ARE THE EXACT SAME PROCESSES.
THAT THE PROFESSIONAL STAFF IN
OUR OFFICES FOLLOW IN ORDER TO
REGISTER AND CONFIRM SOMEONE'S
ELIGIBILITY.
IF THERE'S A QUESTION IN THE
STATEWIDE DATABASE WITHOUT
SPEAKING TOO MUCH ELECTION SPEAK
IT WILL GIVE YOU A YELLOW LIGHT
OR A RED LIGHT.
IF THERE IS NO QUESTION IN THE
STATEWIDE DATABASE THAT'S THE
INFORMATION WE PUT INTO THE
SYSTEM ALL MATCHES THE SYSTEM
CONFIRMS THE PERSON HAS NOT BEEN
ISSUED A BALLOT ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE STATE.
THAT COULD BE COMING BACK AND
THAT THE PERSON IS NOT
REGISTERED AND VOTING A COUNTY
THAT HAS A PAPER ROSTER SO THAT
COUNTY IS NOT CONNECTED TO THE
STATEWIDE DATABASE -- IN THEIR
POLLING PLACES OR VOTE CENTERS
OUR SATELLITE OFFICES IT'S GOING
TO GIVE US THE GREEN LIGHT THOSE
ARE THE EXACT SAME CHECKS WE DO
IN OUR OFFICE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
ONE QUESTION AT SO YOU KNOW IF
YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO COMES AND
SAME DAY VOTER REGISTRATION
[inaudible]
AND AS YOUR PROCESS THEM YOU SEE
THAT THERE REGISTERED IN ANOTHER
COUNTY -- AND THEY'VE ALREADY
BEEN ISSUED AN ABSENTEE BALLOT.
WOULD YOU SAY NO YOU CAN'T BOTH
THAT DAY.
IT WOULD DEPEND.
IF WE GET IF I LOOK UP AND I AM
IN PLASTER COUNTY.
AND SOMEONE HAS JUST MOVED FROM
SACRAMENTO THE PLASTER COUNTY
AND THEY WERE ISSUED A BILL BY
MAIL BALLOT.
IN -- SACRAMENTO COUNTY I WOULD
DO ONE OF TWO THINGS I WOULD
HAVE THEM VOTE A CV ARE BALLOT.
HOLD IT TO CONFIRM AFTER
ELECTION AY THAT THE PERSON DID
NOT RETURN THEIR VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT.
OR IN THE CASE OF SACRAMENTO
COUNTY THEY ARE CONNECTED TO THE
STATEWIDE DATABASE I COULD ISSUE
THE PERSON THE BALLOT HAVE THEM
VOTE IN MY OFFICE.
INSTANTLY MARK THEM AS VOTED
WHICH WOULD VOID THE VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT THEY WERE ISSUED IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SO THAT IF IT
CAME BACK IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO COUNT
THE BALLOT HOW DO WE KNOW THAT.
IT'S THE STATE'S WHAT WE DO
EVERY DAY IN THE STATEWIDE
DATABASE IT'S NO DIFFERENT THAN
IF I CALL UP AND I SAY I LOST MY
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT.
I NEED A SECOND ONE AND THE
COUNTY MALES ME A SECOND ONE IT
INSTANTLY VOIGTS THE FIRST ONE
ALTHOUGH BY MAIL BALLOTS ON THE
VOTE BY MAIL ENVELOPES WHEN THEY
COME BACK.
OUR BAR CODED WITH A VOTER --
VOTER ISSUE ID SO IT'S ABOUT ID
NOT ON THE BALLOT ITSELF BUT ON
THE ENVELOPE AND ALL OF OUR
SYSTEM SCANDALS BARCODES.
AND IF THE FIRST ONE IS VOIDED A
WE CAN NEVER OPEN IT THAT'S
CURRENT STATE LAW AND BECAUSE
YOU MENTIONED PLASTER IN
SACRAMENTO AND AND YOU COULD DO
THAT BECAUSE SACRAMENTO IS ALSO
CONNECTED TO THE VOTE COUNT
DATABASE.
AND SO IT'S ALL ONE DATABASE AND
IF YOU MARKET IS VOID THAT SHOWS
UP SACRAMENTO ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS WILL SEE THAT.
INSTANTANEOUSLY IDEA IN TWENTY
SECONDS SO THEY GET THAT BALLOT
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY THEY'RE
JUST GONNA THROW THAT OUT.
WELL THAT WE DON'T THROW
ANYTHING OUT BUT THEY WON'T OPEN
THE ENVELOPE IT WOULD BE VOIDED.
WILL BE VOIDED AND THEY WOULD
MARK THAT BALLOT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE COUNTED
YES SIR THE ENVELOPE THE
ENVELOPE WHAT IF THEY WOULDN'T
OPEN THEM WHAT IF YOU'RE NOT
CONNECTED.
WHAT IF YOU'RE A COUNTY THAT'S
NOT CONNECTED THAN THEY WOULD BE
CV ARE SO THE BALLOT WILL BE
PLACED IN A CONDITIONAL
PROVISIONAL ENVELOPE?
WE WILL WAIT AND TELL AFTER
ELECTION DAY.
AND THEN WE WOULD PROCESS THOSE
ABOUT TO ONLY HAVE A NORMAL
FIRMS AS THE SAME PROCESS AS
TODAY WE WOULD HAVE TO CONFIRM
THAT THE OTHER COUNTY HAS NOT
RECEIVED OR COUNTED A BALLOT
FROM THAT.
OKAY I BECAUSE I I KNOW IT MAY
BE THAT SOME CONFUSION TO
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THIS WOULD NOW
BE ACCOUNTED BUT UNDER THIS BILL
IT WILL BECOME ACCOUNTED VOTE.
UNDER CERTAIN CONDITIONS.
ON IF THE CERTAINTY GETS RID OF
DOESN'T YOUR BILL GET RID OF
PROVISIONALS FOR IT IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS SO AND AND I'LL
DEFERRED TO THE EXPERT ON WITH
THOSE SITUATIONS ARE BUT BUT IT
IN AND MAYBE I'LL JUST HEAD OVER
TO YOU BUT IT IT'S THE IF THESE
CERTAIN.
SITUATIONS ARE MET AND THEN.
A VOTER OR WILL BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE NORMAL VOTING
PROCESS AND NOT HAVE TO GO TO
THE PROVISIONAL VOTER PROCESS
WHICH IS WHICH IS NOT A GREAT.
EXPERIENCE FOR VOTERS -- AND SO
BUT BUT YOU KNOW AS AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED THE IN THE CERTAIN SET
OF CIRCUMSTANCES I'M TRYING TO
FIND MY NOTES NOW -- HAVE TO BE
MET FOR THE AND LOST MY NOTES
BUT BUT FOR FOR A VOTER TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THIS PROCESS.
THESE CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE
TO BE MET AND IF THERE ANY
THERE'S ANY.
CONFUSION OR QUESTION THEN
THEY'LL HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
NORMAL PROVISIONAL VOTER PROCESS
WHICH IS THAT PROVISIONAL IS
HELD ASIDE.
RIGHT.
IT'S NOT COUNTED.
IS THAT RIGHT IT'S NOT COUNTED
INTEL WE CAN GO TO THE
VERIFICATION PROCESS AFTER
ELECTION DAY AND TELL ME ABOUT
WHAT IS THE VERIFICATION PROCESS
VERIFICATION PROCESS -- YOU'RE
GONNA MAKE ME GO INTO THE
ELECTION SPEAK IS LARGEST IF IT
IS AS BRIEFLY AND ASSEMBLY IS
VERY.
PROCESS IS BASICALLY THE SAME
PROCESS THAT A COUNTY WHO WAS
CONNECTED TO THE STATEWIDE VOTER
REGISTRATION DATABASE ON
ELECTION DAY WOULD FOLLOW.
WE WOULD GO THROUGH CONFIRM THE
PERSON AS AN ELIGIBLE REGISTERED
VOTER.
CONFIRM THAT THEY ARE REGISTERED
IN OUR COUNTY.
CONFIRM THEY DID NOT RETURN
ABOUT IN ANOTHER COUNTY.
AND THAT THEY DID NOT APPEAR ON
THE ROSTER INDEX AND VOTE IN A
COUNTY THAT WAS NOT CONNECTED TO
THE STATE BY REGISTRATION DATA.
SO THAT'S TOTALLY CONFIRM THAT
THEY DIDN'T VOTE SOMEWHERE ELSE
RAPIDLY.
AND THEN IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN
YOU COUNT THAT PROVISIONAL
BALLOT.
S. ROOMING THEY VOTED IN THE
CORRECT VOTING PRECINCTS WE
COUNT THE PROVISIONAL BALLOT IF
THEY VOTED IN A PRECINCT THAT
MAYBE DID NOT HAVE ALL OF THE
ISSUES THAT THEY WERE ENTITLED
TO VOTE ON THEY VOTED IN ONE
PART OF THE COUNTY AND THEY
LIVED IN ANOTHER.
WE WOULD DUPLICATE THE RACES
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO VOTE ON AND
CAL.
OKAY.
BUT NOW WITH YOUR BILL.
IF YOU'RE CONNECTED COUNTY WE'RE
JUST GONNA DO ALL THAT
AUTOMATICALLY ESSENTIALLY
CORRECT.
AND WHAT IF.
THE WHAT IS IT CALLED CALVERT'S.
BOCA VOEPEL.
WHAT IF THE DATABASE IS WRONG
AND LIKE I THINK ONE OF THE WHAT
OPPOSITION IS PLAN AS THEY FOUND
INSTANCES WHERE?
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE REGISTERED
TO MULTIPLE ADDRESSES YOU KNOW
WHERE THERE'S DISPARITIES AND IN
THAT SYSTEM ITSELF I THINK WE
ALSO HAD THE ISSUE A DMV.
REGISTRY IN PEOPLE WHO WERE
INELIGIBLE TO VOTE.
SO I'M ASSUMING.
AT SOME POINT DOES ONE INTO THE
SYSTEM OF THOSE BEEN TAKEN OUT
THERE'S SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DATABASE ITSELF RARE THERE'S
SOME THERE'S A VERIFICATION THAT
HAS TO BE DONE I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT UNDER THIS BILL.
VOEPEL IS THE EXACT SAME SYSTEM
WE USE IN OUR OFFICE.
SO THERE'S NO ADDED CHECK OR
ADDED SYSTEM WE USE IN OUR
OFFICE THIS IS THE EXACT SAME
SYSTEM THAT I WOULD USE IN MY
OFFICE TO CONFIRM SOMEONE'S
VOTER ELIGIBILITY.
THEY JUST HAVE IT IN THE FALL IN
THE VOTE CENTERS OR SATELLITE
OFFICES.
ARE A BIT ARE YOU AWARE I MEAN
FOR TO ME STORIES WHERE THERE
ARE ISSUES WITH THE DATABASE
ITSELF YES AND WE WE ARE
CONNECTED.
TO THE STATE WIDE VOEPEL HELP
DESK WE GET MESSAGES FROM THEM
ON ALMOST A DAILY BASIS THEY DO
CONFIRMATIONS IN THE DMV
INSTANCES THAT HAVE OCCURRED
WE'VE GOTTEN LIST OF THOSE
VOTERS AND EVEN EITHER COUNSEL
THEM ARE CORRECTED THEIR
REGISTRATION.
OKAY SO I MANAGED FROM YOUR
STANDPOINT THERE ARE NO ISSUES
WITH THE DATABASE.
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF AS OF
TODAY.
DOES IT DOES ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP HAVE BEEN THE
DISCREPANCIES HAVE BEEN TAKING
CARE OF THE ONES THAT WE ARE
AWARE OF HAVE BEEN TAKEN CARE OF
YES.
HI THAT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS I
HAVE -- YOU KNOW. FOR ME YOU
KNOW I MEAN I THINK THE ISSUE IS
WHO REALLY WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS INTEGRITY HERE I GET
WITH TECHNOLOGY WE CAN DO THINGS
BUT WHAT TECHNOLOGY THERE'S ALSO
ISSUES THAT CAN ARISE AND WE'VE
HAD SOME ISSUES WITH THIS
DATABASE ALREADY.
SO I THINK LIKE WITHOUT KIND OF
SOME MORE EXPERIENCE WITH THIS.
AT FEEL OF DIESEL HARD FOR ME TO
GET INTO A SUPPORT POSITION ON
SOMETHING THAT.
YOU KNOW WOULD.
TAKE AWAY WHAT IS A LITTLE BIT
MORE IN DEPTH VERIFICATION
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE A
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS BUT I I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO AND AND WITHTHE BILL THANK
YOU MISS RUSSIA AND WHAT MIGHT
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
PLEASE PLEASE CLOSE APPRECIATED --
YEAH I I JUST WANT TO RE
EMPHASIZE WHAT CHANGE IN THE
PROCESS THIS DOESN'T CHANGE THE
DATABASE REMOTE USING A
DIFFERENT DATABASE IN THIS
SITUATION AND ANOTHER DATABASE.
ON THE BACK AND THIS IS THE SAME
PROCESS THAT THAT ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS USE.
WE USUALLY TWENTY OR TWENTY FIVE
DAYS AFTER ELECTION DAY IT'S
JUST THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE MODERN
TECHNOLOGY FINALLY INTEGRATED IN
OUR VOTING SYSTEMS WE CAN DO IT
ON THE FRONT END -- WHICH
CREATES A MUCH BETTER EXPERIENCE
FOR THE VOTER BECAUSE VOTERS
HAVE FAITH THAT THEIR VOTE IS
ACTUALLY BEING COUNTED --
THERE'S A LOT OF DISTRUST AROUND
THE PROVISIONAL BALLOT SYSTEM --
BUT SO -- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
YES I AM.
YES I AM CARRYING FOR A SECOND
SO -- THERE'S A MOTION SIR
MOTION AND A SECOND NOW WITH
THAT THAN SECULAR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BERMAN AYE
BERMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
CALDERON CALDERON I LOW.
WELL I MAYES ANOTHER MAYES NOT
VOTING MULLIN.
MULLIN I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THE THE FIVE ZERO THE
BILLS OUT THE BILLS UP.
MOVING OUT YOUR NEXT BILL MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU AB.
SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN MISTER CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES TECHNOLOGY HAS
BECOME AN INSEPARABLE PART OF
OUR DAILY.
SKEWS ME TECHNOLOGY HAS BECOME
AN INSEPARABLE PART OF OUR DAILY
LIVES FOR MANY IS A RARE
OCCURRENCE TO BE WITHOUT AN
ELECTRONIC DEVICE SUCH AS A
SMARTPHONE SMARTPHONE OR TABLET.
EXISTING AND EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO PUT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AT THE
FINGERTIPS FOR VOTERS MAKING
VOTING EASIER AND ENHANCE VOTER
ENGAGEMENT.
USING EXISTING TECHNOLOGY RATHER
THAN HAVING THE STATE VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDE MAIL TO OUR
RESIDENTS WE CAN SIGN UP FOR A
LECTURE ON A DELIVERY.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE IS
INCORPORATING MORE LINKS TO
INCORPORATE TO IT MORE LINKS TO
IMPORTANT INFORMATION SO A VOTER
AT THEIR POLLING PLACE COULD
BRING UP THE GUIDE ON A
SMARTPHONE OR TABLET.
AND IMMEDIATELY ACCESS THE LIST
OF TOP DONORS TO A MEASURE.
AS FOR EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WILL SOON BE
ROLLING OUT ITS NEW VOTING
SYSTEM ONE OF THE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE THE VOTERS WILL BE TO
SCAN IN QR CODE IT BALLOTS.
FROM THEIR PHONE TO THE VOTING
TERMINALS AT POLLING PLACES.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR ELECTIONS LAWS
DO NOT NECESSARILY CONTEMPLATE
THE USE OF SUCH DEVICES.
AND SOME ELECTIONS OFFICIALS AND
POLL WORKERS OF QUESTION THE
PERMISSIBILITY OF USING
SMARTPHONES OR TABLETS.
AT THE POLLS AB SEVENTEEN OH
SEVEN WOULD CLARIFY THAT A
PERSON MAY NOT BE PROHIBITED
FROM USING AN ELECTRONIC DEVICE.
AT A POLLING PLACE PROVIDED THAT
THE USE OF THE DEVICE DOES NOT
VIOLATE OTHER PROVISIONS OF
EXISTING LAW.
ALL EXISTING VOTER PROTECTIONS
TO ENSURE THAT THE VOTING
PROCESSES PRIVATE AND FREE FROM
INTIMIDATION ACCORDING NATION
WOULD BE MAINTAINED ACCORDINGLY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAY NEVER COME BACK TO THE
MEMBERS FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MR BERMAN AS CHAIR WHICH I TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR OF
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
I DON'T REMEMBER WHO DID WHICH
ONE BUT IF THE THE SECRETARY GOT
IT AND WE'RE GOOD -- SECULAR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOST IS TO PASS BERMAN HI
BERMAN I'D GALLAGHER CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW.
NO I MAYES FI MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER I THAT'S SIX ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT AS CHAIR IT'S ALL
YOUR THE THANK YOU MISTER MAY IS
THAT.
IS ALL THE BILL'S BE ON THE
AGENDA WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
MEMBERS JUST ONLY TO VOTE ON A
COUPLE OF BILLS -- MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE GO
THROUGH THE LIST -- ON CONSENT --
CALDERON.
CHILDREN I LOW.
THOUGH I MAYES MAYES I THIS IS
ONE OF HIS COMBAT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
BUILDING.
FOR THE COUPLE MINUTES.
SEE WHAT I MEAN.
IS A READY ESERVER.
OKAY -- THAT HANDLES THAT FOR
EVERYONE IS CURRENTLY HERE
UNLESS YOU THINK YOU MADE A NOTE.
TO GET.
ANYTHING YOU MISS.
ONE MR LOW.
THANK YOU MONEY THAT ON THE ONE
I BELIEVE I HAVE YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GREAT SO WILL LEAVE -- THE
HEARING OPEN FOR A COUPLE OF
MINUTES FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
WILL GIVE IT UNTIL.
WE'LL GIVE IT THREE MINUTES
[inaudible]
WITH THAT [inaudible]
HI
THERE IS A GERMAN